[Music]
you're far more likely to get someone to
do something productive with their life
if they're passionate about what they're
doing and I know sport can play such a
huge role in helping so many different
sorts of people not just criminals but
people in life is such a powerful thing
and I'm such an advocate of it because
I've experienced it in my own life and
as I said like you're not going to meet
anyone from that extreme of crime than
me I wholeheartedly say that I was one
of the most entrenched criminals you'd
ever meet in your life and sport has
allowed me to give that up that's John
McAvoy this week on the retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what is happening
greetings my name is rich roll I am your
host welcome to the podcast can I tell
you how excited I am about today's
podcast this guy John McAvoy and his
story it is insane John has it is one of
the most compelling improbable riveting
inspirational cautionary and frankly
incredibly cinematic stories that I have
ever heard of my entire life and that is
saying a lot because I've had more than
my fair share of extraordinary
conversations over the years with
amazing human beings so I've been hip to
John and his story for well over a year
at this point maybe two years and I
promised myself that if I ever made it
over to London and I would make sure to
get him on the podcast indeed I was in
London recently and I was able to follow
through on that commitment so I don't
want to say too much I don't want to
give it away so I will only say this
John is a former high profile armed
robber a guy who was essentially born
into a notorious London crime family a
guy who was bred from the get-go to pull
off bank heists I'm not talking about
pickpockets I'm talking about armored
vehicles and banks who ultimately found
redemption through the power of sports
and in my humble opinion John has pulled
off one of the greatest 180 degree life
transformations of all time going from
this guy in a prison cell serving two
life sentences to a guy who breaks both
British and world indoor rowing records
while in prison to becoming the only
Nike sponsored Ironman athlete in the
world as well as a powerful voice for
prison reform you just spoke at the
House of Commons the other week helping
to inspire positive change in others
in all honesty I can't remember being so
excited about an episode and so with
that being said I give you God's so good
to meet you man I've been looking
forward to this for a very long time so
super stoked
have you shared your story with me today
thank you for inviting me I'm Cu Jonah
and privilege and I'm looking forward to
sharing it with you yeah good good good
we're coming to everybody from a
conference room in Shoreditch London
it's a little cavernous in here so it
might sound a little bit
echoey in comparison the way that
podcasts usually sound so you're just
gonna have to bear with it though I
think it's gonna be all fine right yeah
cuz you're gonna get so lost in Sean's
story you see you're not even gonna know
what's happening before we even get into
that what are you what are you training
for right now so my season starts in
three weeks time I raced in Ironman
Hamburg mm-hmm I was meant to be racing
two weekends ago but obviously training
for Ironman you end up developing a lot
of injuries swishes I've got a bit older
side a problem tendon in my foot so I
had to delay to start my race season but
Marvel season kicks off in three weeks
time in Germany cool man so feeling good
injury free yeah yeah I'm much better
now I've been a bit more consistent with
my running I did I wasn't able to run
for three months which killed me because
running is actually the thing I enjoy
the most at a training for Ironman
mm-hmm
but yeah so I'm back on course now and
I'm ready to rock and roll freeze time
read on and you're 33 right now I'm 35
35 35 I'm getting on now the gray hairs
and to date what is your like best
performance um my protein my best
performance would have been Iron Man
Frankfurt two years ago it's basically
when I do an Ironman in 2014 I went for
a stage well went an hour faster every
race I did and that sort of really took
hold and I'd to Diamond Frankfurt um it
was a massive step up in my former city
like nine hours mm-hmm I run nearly it's
up through our mouths and the back end
of it well yeah it was good and it was
bad
because the finger kind of let me down
was my
cycling a bit aha because I just lacked
that riding because I didn't stop trying
so I was very sorry that technical
element at riding a bike and my
cornering and braking and that sort of
stuff like it cost me a little bit well
I mean 2014 was your first Ironman yeah
so you're still brand new into this
whole thing yeah yeah like it's a it's a
massive learning process I've been going
through because it was frustrating as
well because when I was when I was doing
my training and I was training on indoor
like static bikes the numbers that I was
generating that power output and my
physiology like I know I was putting out
the same sort of numbers like FTP tests
that what a lot of sort of like decent
Pro iemon would be putting out mm-hmm
but I didn't seem to be getting that
translation across into roads - yeah
because again I just lack the experience
of riding a bike and and that's I've had
so obviously work on it a lot over the
last few years and and I progressively
have got better but I used to be really
really bad that I used to be famous when
we'd go and training camps the Alps I
would descend on a bike quicker then I
would climb up the other side of the
mountain but I was so frightened or just
I'm holding the brakes uh-huh
so uh that's amazing yeah there's a
difference between the power that you
can generate in a lab and then
translating that into a real world
context right yeah that's like the
learning curve it's totally different
light obviously all of my training I've
ever done for obvious reasons has always
been on static machines yeah so like the
Ryan machine years ago waswas in prison
mm-hmm and then when I come out of
prison I carried on trying to try to
become a professional Rella but I took
up that school too late that's why I
decided to do Ironman
so actually power-generating on a static
machine oh you got that car yeah I was
very very good like what kind of words
were you putting out so that I could
hold like three three hundred and sixty
five Watts when I was like 7 e one kilo
for half hour yeah that's serious yeah
for people that are listening that don't
have a frame of reference that's like
world-class yeah obviously I was
fortunate where the transition between
rowing on a indoor rowing machine that
power you tend to find a lot of rowers
are very very very strong when they make
the transition between rowing
- exactly where it's a leg dominated
sport and also just when you have the
ability to be able to hurt yourself like
I've never physically felt pain like I
felt on an indoor rowing machine in an
Ironman or cycling nothing comes close
like to that when you're on the rivet
right they're not a 2k fat test because
it's like the lactate builds up in every
part of your body your back your legs
your arms when you're in the very
machine yeah and I think that that like
in thinking about your story I mean I
think you have some genetic
predisposition like an ability to
generate huge amounts of power but
you're your gift really is your ability
to to suffer over long periods of time
yeah yeah yeah I would
I would say that born through pain and
life experience as much as anything else
yeah like years ago I wouldn't I
wouldn't have seen it like that but
obviously some of the situation's I
found myself and as a young man and some
of the things that I did to myself like
when I was in prison when I was a young
when I was a young teenager and I
segregated myself you know in an
isolation cell for for a whole year and
that was like defiance against the
system the reason why I chose to do that
was because I got moved to a prison and
they tried to take all my clothes off me
to put me in a special yellow boiler
suit so the prison officers could
identify that I was in the scape risk
and and I was brought up to absolutely
despise and hate the system and
everything he stood for government
politicians banks and then when I found
myself in prison the system become very
real and those prison officers have
locked me up with real people and they
took my freedom away from me and and
when they tried to take my clothes off
me I refused and they took me down to
this isolation cell and they took my
clothes off for me and they gave me this
yellow suit so the prison officers could
identify that I was an escape risk in
the prison and then when the seven days
was up because that was what I was
originally put in there for seven days
and days of solitary so its solitary
they open up the door and they said
you're going to go back on two main
allocation and you're going to be a wing
cleaner and again I hated these people
and and and I said there's no way I'm
gonna go and do that that you're not
good I'm not going to do it I'm not
going to clean up your rubbish every day
so he put me back in front of the
governor the governor said to me you
refuse in another law order and I
suggest he said well you ran back in
that cell for several more days and he
gave me seven days confined to sell
again and then when I was in that
process and I was sitting in that cell
I read about Nelson Mandela and when I
went to prison when I was a young man I
made the decision I would not become
institutionalized and when the librarian
used to come around but this up this
lady from the library she used to come
out of a trolley and you take books off
and and I used to think I will not
become institutionalized I will educate
myself to come out of here and be a
better criminal not not to change not to
rehabilitate because I was brought up to
believe that if you changed you as weak
and the system had broken you so if you
had rehabilitated and become a better
person you became soft a criminal
wouldn't say like that they would see
the system and broken you so I had that
mantra in my head and when I was reading
this book about Nelson Mandela and in
the book he said that when he was in
prison he used to smoke tobacco then he
realized that the prison officers
usually used that as a punishment
against him he stopped smoking
cigarettes so then my head does at this
point I was 19 I thought if you think by
putting me in this isolation cell that
you're punishing me I will take you away
from you so when they come at the seven
days to put me back up on the wing I
refused and then I stayed in that room
for 365 days by choice by choice and
they would come around Christmas and I
remember this and and I look back on it
now like there was a prison officer I
didn't see it at the time I hated him
but I remember he opened up my cell
Christmas and he said to me he was just
about to golf shift and he was in the
evening it was about 4 o'clock so
obviously Christmas people going home
earlier that day and he said to me do
you want a phone up your mum and I said
no and I remember you open up my cell
door and he said look just you can phone
your mum up is Christmas Day and I
refused I said I don't wanna use the
phone because that would give them some
tiny little bit of power if they gave
you something they can take something
away from you yeah and I think it was me
trying to wrestle control of me taking
control back of my body and it
and also again it was that arrogance I'm
not wanting to show them weakness that
even though it was Christmas Day I
wouldn't break and they they wouldn't
get anything out of me and I would sit
and and at that time I thought I was
getting something over on them well in
fact I was only punishing myself and I
was only hurting myself but I didn't see
it like that I saw myself at war with
them and this was about me being defiant
and me not showing weakness and me not
giving in to them well I want to explore
like how that ultimately ended up
shifting and I want to get into like how
you got there in the first place but
before we do that like walk me through
the experience of being in solitary for
such a long period of time like how that
shapes you how you spend your time
trying to expand your mind but also what
you did physically so obviously you've
got 24 hours a day to fill up you get
into a habit of going to sleep very
early I used to make two short choices
as well when I was in there read and I
would not sleep in the day I would not
sleep my prison sentence off so some
prisoners would sleep all day in a
segregation and I chose not to do that
so I got into a routine and when I was a
child I had no interest in sport or
exercise whatsoever never you never
played sports were never an athlete play
football I used to get put in goal I was
the little overweight kid that couldn't
kick a ball but they'd stick me in god I
would always be the last kid to be
picked and go you can go and go but I
had no I never idolized athletes as a
kid I never really had any interest in
sport bar soccer football and that was
about it but when I was in prison when I
was actually locked up someone once said
to me that when you go to prison you
don't live you just exist and I started
off one day and I don't even know what
the trigger was but I started off doing
press ups and I didn't know the names of
the exercises I was doing and then I
would do press ups step up so I'll get
my tum chair and my cell and put it out
into the back of the wall and you could
open up the tiny little vent windows
just to get a bit of ventilation and
I'll start doing any step ups and then
then I'll do sit-ups
and then I start putting all the
exercises together and not do these
circuits and I'll get up every morning
at half five six o'clock and I again I
was grossly unfit when I first went to
prison I was like oh yeah so when you
begin like how many pushups could you
Baba not a lot not a lot yes you could
have been working out it like in the
beginning like okay half an hour I'm
done I kind of just kept pushing myself
so when when I've read live at the ten
the next time I wanna do 11 and so I get
the pain and it hurt and that would make
me feel alive and then I don't about the
other exercises on do ten ten ten and
and as the mumps progressed obviously I
again I didn't realize what I was doing
but I was obviously getting fitter I've
lost weight and and I didn't up doing a
thousand of each exercise and it and in
total he used to take me anywhere
between like an hour to an hour and a
half depending on what sort of exercises
but what I chose to do within it it used
to make me feel alive and again it was
me taking control back from very prison
officers back to myself and that would
last in the morning from 6:00 to so of
Harper 7:00 and then I'd have my
breakfast and then odd read and again
when I was in there because of the sort
of men that brought me up art I remember
um so of one of my stepfather that was a
was in prison for long periods of time
16 years and I asked him how did he stop
himself from becoming institutionalized
as before I went to prison and he used
to listen to the radio every day and he
would make sure that he read newspapers
to stay connected to the real world
because he said this is not my life and
that is them that is sort of again the
mantra that I took on I refuse to accept
where I was nice to things myself this
is not my life so I want to stay
connected to the real world outside of
this wall and I'd be I'd be avidly
reading about current affairs and this
is when I was quite young as well like
politics I would want to stay in touch
with what was happening in the real
world because this where I was at the
moment these people would kidnap me hmm
again they hadn't I broke the law and I
was in prison for it right and your
sentence you know it was a life sentence
was it not that when I first went when I
was as a teenager that was I got five
years for
of firearms and then when I went back
the second time obviously because I had
previous convictions and and the judge
expressed my links to the criminal
underworld
it was so extensive at such a young age
he said no matter what sentence he gave
me that day I was still gonna come out
of prison the young man because I was
only 24 and he said that he believed
that my risk to the public was so great
that they would always need protect him
from me so he sent this me to two life
sentences with a live with a minimum
tariff for five years and what that
meant is because sometimes people get
confused what a life sentence is so as
we speak to that II I am technically
serving my prison sentence in the
community so at any moment the police
suspected I was involved in any
organized crime I was seemed of any
organized criminals they could recall me
straight back to prison and I'll go back
on to my life sentence and then I would
have to go back up in front of a parole
board and demonstrate to them that I
wasn't a risk to the public and that was
what it was about it was about taking
the burden of proof from the police
having to prove I was committing a crime
to them suspecting I was committing a
crime it was easier to recall me back to
prison so to this day you could easily
go back yeah if you even tiptoed
anywhere near any of this yeah even when
I went to go abroad to race um I did a I
did a talk last week at Nikes European
headquarters in Amsterdam and I have to
ask for permission off vibration officer
and then when I come back to the country
after the gun report in to her to prove
that I've returned back to United
Kingdom so that will always hang over me
I don't I don't look at it like and be
bitter and twisted about it like I got
the sense I know why the judge gave it
to me back then but my life's obviously
moved on to such an extent now that yeah
would be nice if it wasn't hanging over
me but his hair it is and and there's no
point me stressing about it every day
waking up thinking I've got this
sentence hanging over my head I've got
try to just let go of that because I I
don't want to become bitter and twisted
and angry you could be back in right now
I mean you could still be in there right
so Lobby days a gift
based upon you know that Judge hundred
hundred percent in your actions a
hundred percent and and that is why I've
got an appreciation of life and how
precious life actually is because when
you go to prison and again I it's not a
hard
story like I put myself in there by poor
decisions I chose to make as a young man
but when you go to prison it is as near
to Diane is what you could possibly get
but being in the black shawl being alive
still like it's like you in term your
body into a concrete coffin and when you
get those life sentences like you've got
a minimum tariff but I can remember the
day when my minimum tariff expired I
went to bed and woke up the next day and
I'm still in prison and then you realize
how powerless you are it's actually if
the system doesn't want to let you out
you will stay in there for the rest of
your life if you don't play the game
with them so books you read the Nelson
Mandela book what were the other books
that were impactful on you Malcolm X
like I can't you know there's like a
list there's like a bibliography of
books that are most commonly read and in
prison yeah I think when I was in there
I was very interested in history I've
always had this fascination even since I
was a little kid I think that was one of
the catalysts why I end up doing what I
done when I was a kid so my biological
father passed away if I was born and my
mum explains to me about he died and I
was only young I was like five six years
old when I was going to primary school
and because kids kept teasing me where
my dad was and my mum she transmitted
with death was and I was too young to
really understand what legacy was but I
developed this this insatiable appetite
for history like I can remember my mom
used to get these magazines every month
called discovery booklets and it'll be
about a Napoleon Winston Churchill and I
can remember in a little boy and
hundreds of years after these men were
dead people still reading about them and
they left the footprint on the earth and
and that motivated me I remember
thinking like I don't just want to die
though I want to achieve something with
my life and that thread of that one in
to learn about the past always stayed
with me so when I was in prison I kept
reading about the past because I still
wanted that legacy
I still want introduce out my life
mm-hmm and when I decided to make that
connection about changing years later
like I said the when I read Lance
Armstrong's autobiographies that a
profound
hats on me that opened up my eyes to a
possibility of like the characteristics
that I had that were that I was using
that the will to drive the one intuitive
saying of life went to be successful the
only people that I ever met in my life
with those characteristics were all
involved in organized crime then
suddenly I was opened up to this man
that did sport and they were massive
attributes they and he was successful
and then I started reading the reserve
books of all these sort of Olympic
athletes and endurance athletes and
again they all had the same reoccurring
blueprint of the same characteristics
hmm but you're thinking at the time like
how you can channel those
characteristics to become a master
criminal honestly by rich I'm very
fortunate that since I've been at a
prison I have a lot of friends and
associates that have gone to the
Olympics and they've meddled they won
gold medals at the Olympic Games very
pinnacle in rowing and what sport
they've chosen to though they've been
highly successful they work for like
Goldman Sachs Mobil inch big financial
institutions and when I when we train
together there's a couple of them what
we go for runs on the weekend like long
runs and and I've said to them before
you would be amazed the conversations
that we're having about the world I'd be
having is that the same conversations
with people that were in prison for
being contract killers for people
involved in drug trafficking you will be
amazed the similarities in the mindsets
of the two of them but how from a young
person their lack of opportunity or the
bad role models that have come into
their lives that have warped what
they've then chosen to do with those
characteristics and they've been exposed
to criminality and they've thrown that
in to crime and they was exposed to
rowing or sport and their fathers work
for big corporate banks and and they've
chosen that path and it even fascinates
me sometimes like the cook the the
similarities and the conversations
routine to groups of people and the
mindsets are exactly the same that's
profound
and fascinating the same mindset the
ability to focus uniquely on a specific
goal and work
you're way towards that whether it be
criminal or athletic or professional
yeah I can see how those traits would
cross over and the differentiator is of
course the environment yeah that's a
that's amazing some some and again so
give me a taste of like the that kind of
conversation amidst you know the
criminal underworld because I know what
the I know what the athlete
conversations obviously in the criminal
for sanity everything revolves around
money acquiring money making lots of
money you tend to find with a lot of
people who commit crime what they've got
that a lot of normal members of society
haven't got is there's no real cut off
switch like there's nothing they're not
really prepared to do that there I was
brought up with a moral compass and you
don't hurt women
you don't hurt children you you don't
sell heroin you don't have old people
you don't you don't attack the working
man but the system and everything the
system is fair game
mm-hmm and everyone that I was around as
a criminal all had that same belief
system and so you turn to pretend to
find your whole conversations were based
around making money but making it
through the system and that would be
through sort of committing robberies
people committing fraud but all against
not against business but against going
there is a code right yes the way that
you see it you know my only frame of
reference is what you see on television
and movies you know but if you watch
Goodfellas or The Sopranos and you know
movies of that ilk stories told of that
ilk like there's always that code right
and that code cannot be transgressed and
in when you're part of that universe it
all makes sense yeah like my my stepdad
used to say to me when I was a young boy
must've been that ten eleven years old
the only thing in that world that you've
got is your name and if people don't
respect you because you've informed and
your friends or informed on anyone and
you've sort of grasped ratted people out
and don't do anything
your name's finished and the only thing
you have ever got is that as a criminal
it goes before you like if people don't
think you what you
classroom crimes countries being any
good that's the end of you is doing what
you're doing being been been involved in
criminal activity yeah but like again if
I was ever disrespectful to a woman in
any way like touch the woman was
disrespectful verbally so ah my stepdad
would have gone absolutely mad my mum
would have gone absolutely mad but my
stepdad would not tolerate it you'll
treat women respect because your mum's a
woman
your sisters a woman and I and I found
that quite fascinating because as my
life's progressed since I've been out of
prison
there's been occasions where I've met
women and their parents are found out
about my past and the kind of lie all
you've got to be careful but the irony
of it is there probably be safer with me
than they would for someone else where I
see a we believe on them that's so funny
like yeah armed robbery no problem you
know good on you pat on the back but you
know sort of set a weird thing to a
woman or touched her inappropriately and
like not so good hmm so let's take it
back to the beginning so you you never
you never really knew you're your
biological father
no but give me a sense of like the
family that you grew up in what the
environment was like so my my actual
biological father he died when twice my
mum was eight months pregnant with me so
he went to bed one night he was 38 years
old and had a massive heart attack it
was there was no symptoms there was
nothing leading into it that led him to
believe he had a bad heart my mum said
that he was a he was an absolute
workaholic like he wasn't a criminal he
owned nightclubs betting offices he had
sharps construction business but all
legitimately he didn't he didn't my mom
you say to me he was a smell sort of
like it does the terrain of the mouth
does and and all of him to be fair all
of his brothers like they were from a
big Irish Catholic family a lot of them
were involved in crime but my dad my mum
you saved my dad used to look at them
they're all idiots because he could see
the Ryan was on the wall with them but
what my dad did because my mum told me
that because I own stuff like nightclubs
and then he owned betting offices
because he had these different sorts of
businesses he
staying up all night at the nightclub
making sure that people wasn't stealing
money and then he was waking up again at
five six o'clock in the morning and then
going out in the construction business
and so he was surviving on very little
sleep lot of stress and anyway bad diet
dies at 38 years old I get born into the
world and I had a relatively sort of
what are the classes are no more bring
in like I wasn't abused Christmases come
round everything I ever wanted my mum
loved me I had loads of on his no real
men come into our lives
my mum was single only uncles come into
our home and it was just a normal child
like I said earlier on the only thing
that really made you a bit different was
when I sat down to primary school people
used to tease me about not having a dad
and I asked my mum and my mom told me my
dad died and then my life completely
changed when I was 8 years old and
before my mum met my father my mom grew
up in her place in South London called
Peckham and she grew up on a council
estate and she grew up with a man called
Billy Tobin and they got they would grow
I grew up as kids and when I was 16
they're both Catholics they get married
my mom falls pregnant my sister when
she's 18 they're just a normal young
family in London Billy goes out was dead
one night and he's working as a
plasterer and he sees his dad get
murdered in a pub and free men so that
is that's death when that happened
Billy's life then completely spiraled
and then I don't know I couldn't tell
you what was going through his head but
I could only imagine he then looked at
life and he then went on a journey of
becoming a normal guy plasterer young
family to becoming one of the most
prolific armed robbers in the United
Kingdom he had five acquittals at the
Old Bailey the police shot him two times
on robberies he was a multi-millionaire
when he's 21 8 years old this man comes
out of prison after serving 16 years and
he come into our home when I lived in
Crystal Palace my mum in South London
first time I will ever buy
seen this man and he was I commemorate
as clear as day I come in I was a young
kid I'm looking at him he was
immaculately dressed massive gold watch
and he come in our home and he asked me
to make him a cup of tea and I made him
his cup of tea and then as he's leaving
our house he gave me a 20-pound note it
was the first time anyone had ever give
me paper and I took this 20-pound note
of him and he patted me on the head and
he meant you a good boy
and he left and I said to my mom who is
he and my mom explained to me that it
was her ex-husband he didn't say like if
you want a job you know come and see me
no no he's very cinematic you know it's
like a it's like I can see it happening
it's like in the movies he to be honest
he never ever ever ever to talk so he
didn't come into my life but to my mum's
life again to be in a romantic
relationship but obviously cause of my
sister yeah he's around yeah he's around
84 and he didn't live with my mum he's
living his own life and when he used to
take my sister out he would take me out
he didn't have a son I didn't have a dad
so you can already see what start has
happened here and he never ever ever
mentioned to me anything he did and he
would take me to these restaurants and
there'd be a lot again a young kid lot
of older men big watches nice cars
outside couple stop and by the table to
say hello
oh all of that stuff like going into
restaurants being in good tables never
having to queue you could see when you
into clothes shops the people in the
clothes shops treat them differently
everything was cash Christmas from come
round I remember like them all putting
money together and giving you like a
thousand pounds when I was a young boy
always always always talking about money
every conversation was about money and
that was it but no one really went into
detail where the money was coming from
and again you were a young boy I
couldn't connect the dots up and it was
only when my granddad died that me and
my mum and my auntie's went mad to my
granddad's flat to clear it out and as I
opened up the store there was a massive
envelope and I even got this envelope
and it had all of these front page
newspaper clippings from all right the
national tabloid newspapers and it was
basically Billy on the front of them and
it was like harried sort of noble juries
which meant corrupt juries paid them off
to find not guilty
police were after him for years and how
he was the most influential bank robber
in the country and that they organized
crime and millions of pounds and I was
reading all these newspaper clippings
and then I then connected up the dots
where all of this sort of this money and
your how old it this why I was 12 years
old
mmm and it really that didn't send me
over the edge that wasn't the the
catalyst for me decided to do what I did
that come a little bit further along but
it all started happening around the same
sort of time I asked Billy about this
and he didn't really want to talk about
he didn't ever ever ever really talk
about when he was in prison he didn't
like really doing it unless I really
used to push him on it but then when I
was 12
big TV channel in his country ITV there
was a dog there was a film so I not a
documentary film and this film was about
my real brother my real dad's brother
and he committed the biggest armed
robbery in the world and he stole 26
million pounds worth of gold bullion at
Heathrow Airport and we're not go out
Billy as a young kid again all the dots
I connect and up everyone would go is
that Mickey's nephew and I never used to
really question it and a note day
vanHoose always like that was why they
was giving me the money at Christmas and
that was why they was always making sure
that if I haven't I wanted anything like
Jim did you want a drink you want this
you want that so did Mickey Mickey got
killed or he was in prison he was in
prison so right Mickey McEvoy yeah and
he got 20 25 years for the armed robbery
of stealing gold bull right so we're
paying respect to Mickey was too slippy
you cash yes yeah yes because we've in
crime in the United Kingdom obviously it
was the biggest armed robber in the
world
you're then dealing with men that hate
the system you've attacked the system on
unimaginable scale and stolen which if
you put it into today's money would
probably be a couple of hundred million
pounds worth of gold bullion cuz this
was like 19 1983 yeah so if you put into
real-world terms to that he how much
money that be worth so have in the
criminal underworld in this country it
was it was the pinnacle of doing
anything to assist them and then you've
got this young kid sent out with this
very
by profiler armed robber that's then
going into this world with other high
profile gun eyes criminals as a blood
relative of that man
so then what that then started doing
when I watched that film that film
inspired me that night and honestly rich
I genuinely feel embarrassed to say but
it inspired me to become a criminal I
didn't see the fact that my uncle was in
prison for 25 years for that offense oh
I saw a Hollywood actor sitting on 26
million pounds worth of gold bullion and
that to me at that moment was pathway
for how I could become rich and how I my
definition of success was how much money
I would make and that was the pathway in
which I was going to choose to do it hmm
so then really that sort of age I then
saw death complete disinterest in school
complete disinterest right and we're
talking about when we're talking about
like a criminal enterprise and we're
talking about armed robbery we're not
talking about holding people up on the
street you're talking major bank
robberies like like big heists and an
organized and organizational structure
beneath this that's supporting this
endeavor right yeah so how vast was the
enterprise when when when I started
getting involved in crime then properly
when I when I left school nor 16 i sat
my GCC's because my mum paid me to sit
them but I knew that I know English on
maps it wasn't gonna get me wondering in
life but I dumped medusa seas and and i
remember when i sat there and i I got my
grades at the end of the summer my head
of year was there and he gave them to me
and even if only you would have applied
yourself what you could have done and I
still managed to salvage some decent
grades considering I did none of the
course work made him and I've got these
qualifications I ripped them up chucked
them in a bin at the end of my school
drive and I thought I'm no I'm gonna go
and do my stepdad found out that I
bought a firearm when I was 16 and in
his head he believed that I would be
safe for committing crime with them then
I would be people my own age and
overseas Yeah right
it is yes it is there's a logic there
protecting you and trying to prevent me
from killing
myself or killing someone else and
meanwhile your mom had to see the the
signals all right so where's she in this
my mum right when I was a young boy
growing up to the degree my mum would
not even let me play with shorter guns
like Cowboys she would not like she did
everything she could to shield me to the
degree she told Billy never ever ever
take him and do anything with him so
when he would swing by and take you out
of these restaurants was she I mean she
must have said at some point like look
he gotta stay away from this guy she did
but the problem that you start getting
is when you're a young teenager or a
young man you become harder and harder
and harder for your mum to control what
you're doing because you always think
your arms wrong I look back now my mum
everything my mum said was right but
it's very hard for a woman to control a
young man this then ran these such
dominant strong alpha males their
enticing you in to that world it's like
a lot of those guys that that I knew has
grown up as kids a lot of their kids
went to private schools they the best
education you can falter by basically
they're all in private schools they went
on lavish holidays around the world they
had nice things tennis court some garden
every single one of those kids left that
private school and they become drug
traffickers and it all ended up in
prison but they had the best of
everything and that just shows you what
happens when you have that terrible role
model like they had the best of
everything they they they come out of
school with top grades top school and
come out and end up selling drugs
because their dad sell drugs and it
wasn't discouraged in fact most of the
time dad's got the sons on board and the
sons got involved in their empire in
their drug empires or got involved in
whatever criminality they would commit
him my stepdad realized that I was
following him in that line so like I
said he evil in a in a full sense of
protecting me if he's safer if I commit
a crime of him than other people so he
then basically used to get me to go out
and with video cameras and and I would
film vidura's making deliveries to
security they're posed in the suburbs
and they would basically fill up the
security they're posed and I'll give
these CCTV a so it's like Ricard yeah
open out a job you got to figure out how
the money's flowing so you know where
the vulnerability is like my my my role
in it become I used to be very good at
memorizing number plates so like I look
back on it now so I would go out and
like in a car or a motorbike and
obviously if you're you're delivering
money to sort of banks in armored trucks
that you could call them security rounds
in the armored trucks the same van used
to make the same delivery on the same
day every week week on week on week and
you know how many saw how many times is
walking in that the bank how much he was
taken in that the bank so you would know
on a Thursday they was delivering X
amount of hundreds of houses a pound
into each bank these guys that work for
these companies aren't looking at a 17
16 year-old kid they're looking for
middle-aged men stocky stubble like your
typical criminal not some sort of spotty
teenager that's a little bit of a chubby
but they're not looking at me as a
threat
so it's very easy for you to like get
near them and count and look and observe
and then part for me later information
back on I realized very quick that my
goal was to be a millionaire that but
that was it bottom line and I set myself
goals I want to be worth four million
Pamela was 21 years old and then as I
got older I wanted more and more money
mm-hmm but there was these goals and was
your stepdad like look just we're gonna
bring you in we're gonna start you with
small stuff but be patient
and you will be a millionaire like was
there it was it overt and explicit like
that well it was it was it was the only
way I can explain what he was like so he
never used to stop telling me that he
was a millionaire when he was 21 that so
that was why that stuck in my head and
he always used to say to me do you think
you'll beat me and it was like a test
and even little things like when I was
at school he had a Porsche 911 and I was
being a bit cheeky to my mum because I
was true an Indian when I go to school
and I said we live too far they're gonna
go die and get in the bus and he said
take the car I'm 16 years old and I said
what he said take the car he said you're
a big man take the car drive to drive to
school so said I so I took his car and I
drove the car to school now most adults
you wouldn't let a child drive any car
but let alone a car like that it was all
it was all that was what he was like he
was always testing
he was always seeing how much bottle I
had and did did I have that sort of
capability to keep pushing it and what
started happen when he was when I was
out with him now remember this and he
was relaying these stories onto older
men that at this time I knew that
revolved in crime David glavish preys on
you and they would show you respect and
and that starts feeding psychology as a
young man
especially a younger boy and you're
getting these like 40 50 year-old men
saying call you got some but all like I
would've done that and I was a kid and
that's not speeding into it and then you
start again you've got no fear I had an
unfair I didn't fear the police so then
I was brought up didn't mean anything to
me
Farah a prison police none of that
bothered me so I had literally zero fear
so if they said to me go and drive 10
guns to the other side of the country or
look important in a car and drive there
cuz it was all able and actually did die
was inside that was at it but they
actually did do that there was a couple
of times where they did do that and
sometimes I'll go back on it now and I
think they're kind of exploiting me to a
degree and I've been I was too young to
understand that I fall I was in I was
even with him and when actually it was
about me taking these massive risks
right cuz you're the one who's gonna
take the fall Yeah right
and you're you're you're expendable hmm
right yeah the amazing thing is that we
don't like to think that if we found
ourselves in your shoes that we would
make a different choice and it's just
not how it works you know it's like this
slow drip of you growing up in this
certain environment and you know a
billion small encounters and exchanges
with people that leads you to that place
where the obvious choice is to do
exactly what you did and that if I had
grown up in that environment that I
would have made the same choices do you
know what rich what's that that's how he
did me like so much what I've gone on to
do with my life because I can have this
conversation that we're having right now
with a politician and and I have
countless times I've met people in
authority and they sit across the table
for me and they go I cannot see how
you've gone to prison for what you've
gone in there for even when I was in
prison on parole hearings I'm sitting
with my probation officers that have
been in that system for you
and they're like looking at afar looking
at me looking at foul looking at me
again I cannot see how you come across
the way you doing you've done this and
that what that has done for me is I can
express and show them what can happen to
young people the most intelligent
articulate driven focused young men that
there are up and down this country when
negative people come into their lives
and how that intelligence and drive and
focus can can be completely and utterly
warped and and that's why we've got this
huge problem in our country the moment
with young kids killing each other
getting involved in gangs or in America
they're not not ambitious and they're
not not driven like they're incredibly
ambitious and driven but it's all
channeled into the wrong thing because
the wrong people have come into their
lives and channeled that energy into
something so destructive and they don't
see the destructive nature of what
they're really doing until it eventually
leads to them being killed or spending
their lives in prison Lee yeah a big
part of what you do probably the most
important part you know if everyone
knows you is this triathlete but you
know with this incredible story but it's
your advocacy on behalf of prison reform
you know that that that I think you know
holds the most power to really shift
culture and if you just scroll through
your Twitter feed like you're constantly
talking about what's not going right
what needs to be changed there was just
the thing the other day about somebody's
trying to get incarcerated individuals
into sport while they're incarcerated
but it was like dismissed or something
like that and you had a few few words to
share about that yeah right
she took yet a tabloid newspaper sort of
with political agendas that don't
necessarily want things to change when I
was in prison the second time there were
85 thousand men incarcerated there was
28 of us that 85,000 that were deemed to
such a higher risk that we had to be put
in a special high-security prison unit
in Belmarsh prison called the h issue we
were completely an at least segregated
out the whole prison system because we
we were deemed to be a threat to
national security or our sky was so
highly likely and we did ask Amy to pose
such a risk to the police that escape
must be made impossible and I was kept
in that unit for two years with Islamic
suicide bombers mm-hmm the system wrote
me off said ah you were in there with
like Hamza so shake shake a boot on sir
right um the 21-7 suicide bombers that
tries to blow themselves up on the
underground system and the guys that
tried to actually blow up their
transatlantic flights came over to the
states with a liquid bombs so I'm in
there with them I'm told basically
you're here because we believe you're
going to escape and the likelihood of
you changing got two life sentences is
so slim it will not happen and I can
remember someone from the Home Office
was like the Ministry of Justice come
into the prison and I was trying to get
off this unit trying to get into the
main prison because I did actually want
to try to escape or get out as fast as I
could and she said we're not stupid we
know people like you will never ever
ever change because again you serious
crime and and if I have managed to do
why I've done through spall why can't
the other eight and five thousand people
do it and and that's what makes me so
passionate because I understand that
once I had an awakening in prison and I
wanted to do something else with my life
and I had discovered sport what sport
done for my life and sport allowed me to
be successful it gave me it's given me
everything I've got today and it isn't
even about being a good athlete it's
about what it's done for my life it's
about the people was bought into my life
incredible people not just the Olympic
athletes but it's allowed me to go in
and speak to kids thousands of them up
and down the country I've met some of
the most amazing incredible people I've
ever met in my life through sport now it
doesn't mean you have to come out you
have to break World Records in prison
but it gives you access and exposure to
positive people and that is what sport
done and when I got released from prison
my social circle completely changed
overnight and and I'm friends with
nearly everyone that I was friends with
when I first come out and it broke me
away from that those negative people
that were involved in crime and I know
sport can play such a huge role in
helping
so many different sorts of people not
just criminals but people in life is
such a powerful thing and I'm such an
advocate of it because I've experienced
it in my own life and as I said like
you're on you're not gonna meet anyone
as each from from that extreme of crime
than me like I I will wholeheartedly say
that I was one of the most entrenched
criminals you'd ever meet in your life I
wasn't a horrible bully
I didn't bully normal people can a
banana sure I wasn't that sort of like
Mafia don boss that bullied people and
tried to take money from restaurants and
stuff but I was driven by greed and
everyday and sport has allowed me to
give that up and I would imagine one
thing you come across regularly is this
idea that the more you accomplish the
more you achieve the more you become an
outlier so that somebody can say to you
yeah Jon like look what you did but
you're you're like you're the you're the
unique example like this is not gonna be
the case for all these other people so
like why even try I would say - I would
say to anyone that says that like I have
I've gone in visited prisons and I've
gotten visited young offenders and
schools and and I'm not the only person
there there are countless stories of
other people that have used sport and
this place has a massive role in their
lives and they've they've it's allowed
them other opportunities to be better
people again I understand is varying
there's varying levels of it and I know
I've probably taken it to the extreme
because of the characteristics of which
I've always possessed the ambition or
Drive I was in prison when I was good at
sport when it's be a millionaire next
thing was I want to be a professional
athlete but I've always had that but
I've always been ambitious and driven
and and I know you you can get varying
levels of that but it's about what sport
can just give people to be better people
and access and as I said again it comes
back to like I said earlier about having
negative role models in people's lives
this can expose them to positive role
models in people's lives and and I've
also noticed that when I go into these
prisons and I talked to in mates you're
far more likely to get someone to do
something productive with their life if
they're passionate about what they're
doing and I am yet to go into a prison
or young offenders and talk to an inmate
one
one so you tend to find I've got this
sort of I'm fortunate where when I go
into a prison environment prisoners
don't see me as did system they don't
see him as enemy so they're quite open
with their talking so they're very quite
open about what they really think and
the amount of conversations I've had
with inmates where they've certainly
where they've gone I said doc what would
you want to do if you got out of it and
it's been be a personal trainer be a
coach work with children give back but I
never said be a better criminal but I
don't want to be it but if they want to
turn their life they want to change it's
about they you're more likely to get
them to stick it if they're passionate
about it and most prisoners in prison a
passionate about the gym the gym is the
most popular thing in prison other than
food so their food then it will be Jim
and the take-up rate again like we was
having this conversation and Ministry of
Justice like within the prison system so
ethnic minorities make up often 25
percent of our prison population they
attend the gym more regularly than
Caucasian men in the gym system in the
prison system in this country so you can
engage with some of the most
disenfranchised people involved in gang
activity straight away you've got them
in your they're susceptible then to
change and if you say look this you've
shown and positive role models and your
Shannon ways that way they can get away
from that life by becoming a personal
trainer or doing something that they're
passionate about when they get released
they're far more likely to stick it than
if you basically give them a
qualification that they've got no
interest in doing that when they get out
of prison yeah III mean I'm not that
familiar with UK's prison system and I'm
certainly no expert in the prison
industrial complex in the United States
but you know at the core of this whole
thing is not just you know punishment
but rehabilitation and we've just lost
any appreciation for how to properly
rehabilitate people when they're in
prison there doesn't seem to be very
much energy put into that and what we do
is we just create you know we're just
perpetuating and increasing the you know
the criminal underclass
result and in the United States I don't
know what the statistics are but it's
it's far more ethnic and minority than I
would imagine it is here and the prisons
are privatized so we have a built-in
incent incentivization to incarcerate
more and more people keep them in there
longer and longer and longer because
money is being made and there are you
know vested interests and lobbying
groups that are trying to only you know
increase the scope of a system that is
inherently broken and and what you're
saying there is if you look at like the
European model of incarceration so the
United Kingdom hands out more life
sentences a year than the whole
condition of Europe puts together such
staggering
our justice model is far more similar to
yours in the States than it is Europe
and we've got what 12 miles of water
between us and then between us and like
continental Europe and again
privatization of prisons incentivizing
so another example I went into a prison
recently so a prisoner was being paid so
he had no money so he was in prison
he's got no cash outside no real family
he's been paid to go to the workshops
fire palace session to make a Filofax
so he's you I've got that choice or
earning one pound 50 to go to English
for maps he's got no money so what does
he pick
he wants to buy tobacco and he wants to
buy tins of cheering so he goes a bit
elephant and he even said to me what am
I gonna do when I get out of prison
making file faxes and that is the
problem like you've just said if you
incentivize that part of prison and you
start putting in call centers and you
pan them 50 pence a session you give him
like five or six sessions a day and
there were only like 20 30 pounds per
week or they're gonna do in education
and learn someone can better their lives
and they're only getting paid four
pounds a week
it's quite simple where they're gonna go
and where that that flow is going to end
up banned and then you get this huge
problem that we've got at the moment
where it's costing 15 billion pounds a
year on people just coming out of prison
and going straight back in again within
a year see you
huge recidivism so if you had your
druthers what is the reform that you
would like to see that you think is
actually achievable I think there has to
be a yes III do genuinely believe that
spall in prisons could be a far more
powerful use toll than it is at the
moment as things stand we're just it's
like a dog chasing its towel like
there's a shortages of prison officers
you that needs to increase because again
if you ain't got the prison officers you
can't let the prisoners out to engage
and access the courses and and stuff to
help them sort of change but I have
barely spoke play a far more pivotal
role in what actually does at the moment
I sport an exercise in prisons is used
but it's not used to the degree in which
it could I think if you used it in
prisons I think straightaway prison
facilitators violence would drop
dramatically because you're allowing
young men so vent that anger and
frustration through physical activity
whilst they're in prison again I think
you you then they're more susceptible to
change I think that wouldn't necessarily
just keep getting up every morning be
driven by hatred towards the system and
again lots of in the gym setting in
prisons that relationships so different
to the relationship is between guards at
work on the prison wings and prisoners a
prison has changed my life if it wasn't
for that Darren Davis the the prison
also allowed in Granger didn't just
noticed my athletic ability but he
actually had an interest and in me being
successful with no agenda like he used
to come in on his days off and sit with
me as I've tried to break some of the
records on the round machine and he'd
bring me in books and he'd talk about
his family and I've developed a
relationship with him and that's to boot
like yeah well that that does not happen
and that just shows you that when you
get people like the prison officers that
if you have if they're like Darren and
they can reach out to people and they
treat them like human beings and go I
want you to be successful a lot of these
young men it's the first time someone's
ever really wanted that for them yeah
but I would imagine a lot of the you
know these officers they're just they're
just hardened you know they're used to
being on the receiving end of you know a
lot of difficult situations and they
just become emotionally checked out
so I mean that I mean how unique was the
scenario where this guy took an interest
in you he is a very special man like
that shall ever doubt like he the way
and that's what that wasn't just with me
that that's what he's continued to of
his job to today Marquis the way he
treats him mates he treats him like
humans he gives him a chance like to the
degree where there's been occasions
where he said altercations about
prisoners and the prisoners are stuck up
for him over the other prisoners I'm
Annette were never been out of in
arguments I think someone like Darren
and me together collectively we can
change mindset because I think you can
go in and talk to these prison officers
and say you're not just paid here to
open up a door and lock it up you're
here like you are the front line to help
these men change their lives and show
them this job satisfaction and and you
actually have been appreciated that
you're doing a massive task because also
of course like you when I've got into
prison you talk to the prison officers
at you I totally get a view if you're
underpaid and you don't feel like the
system and the government really looking
after you you've got an addition you've
got this complete disinterested in your
job really like you and if you've got no
passion for it and you look at prisoners
like scumbags and you just think I'm
just gonna lock them out like a combo
video of them I'm not paid enough you
again the circle just keeps continuing
and these guys get out and they foster
more hatred towards the system and they
come out and then the offending gets
progressively worse yeah so you should
you should go and maybe you already do
this but when you go and you give talks
you should go out together with them
right yeah we're going to do that we've
done here we've done some joint talks
together but if something you definitely
like I want to develop as good obviously
I've got the balance neck to the moment
what I'm doing them right in iron man
and then once that sort of that's put to
bed that will free me up a lot more to
do a lot more things that I want to sort
of do right right right
well let's let's bring it back to you
know this sort of the development of
your criminal career so you're scoping
out the the armored trucks and when does
it get like more serious to where you're
actually committing these crimes and
participating in them so that was when I
was like 17 I then started getting more
and more involved and my step that gets
arrested
loads of his associates got arrested and
he was the only one that wasn't arrested
and I remember the morning of his arrest
I said to him that you need to go and he
was so arrogant he was like they never
had to touch me and then later on that
day they did they and that rest him
armed police
so I knew it was probably highly
probable that the police were fully
aware of me and again my arrogance was
they can't do nothing to me there's not
enough evidence there was enough
evidence they arrested me because I knew
where I was and they didn't touch me but
what I did though they set a
surveillance operation up on me
and when I was going to go and commit an
offense one morning they were waiting in
ambush and basically cars come from
everywhere by this car chase I got away
every originally was the furthest I've
ever run like I can remember jumped over
Woody's garden fences and those being
chased by police and I actually got away
from them and I felt like I was gonna
have an asthma attack because I was so
unfair and I was in this telephone but
what was the crime you were trying to
commit so he was waiting for well we
went there the night before to park up
all the cars and we were going to commit
a robbery on a caching transit van that
was making a delivery to the post office
so what we did we went there the night
before to park the cars out in the
vicinity and the police watch the
sturdiest so they knew it was gonna
happen next morning and then they
basically were waiting in ambush for us
and then on the way there they decided
to try to arrest us and that's where the
car chase happened and I said I got away
from the actual car chase and I was
jumping over all these garden fences and
I got to a telephone box and I remember
I always tapped 20 pounds in my sock to
get a taxi home if anything ever went
wrong and an ex-felon I heard the
screech and I looked round and saw this
massive man running towards me ever done
pointing to me and I thought I was dead
like I genuinely thought I'm dead and he
they he comin to the phone box and there
was loads of others in my peripheral
vision they dragged me on the floor and
he identified himself as a police
officer a photographer God for that I
thought I was gonna be killed and so
that was your first arrest yes and did
they get you were they trying to spin
you or roll you to get some bigger names
yeah yeah yeah right
yeah cuz you're the young yeah you're
the lowest on the totem pole right
but they're they they they were they
were trying to intimidate me but then
when we got to the police station like
there was a very famous criminal lawyer
in Britain and everyone most
high-profile criminals use him so when
I'd like to when I got to the police
station like it's getting more and more
like a movie it was he was it was he was
like a family lawyer and the UM yeah and
they basically was on the phone he said
don't don't tell nothing mum I send
someone down and then I was there for
three days and and then then they try to
get really pally with you and it's all
like you'll really sort of well you'd
like your uncle and it tried to like you
become they try to become proudly with
you even or not they're trying to that
gets snippet they're trying to get you
to less than the mask and you let
something slip out yeah and I was there
for three days and it was just no
comment no comment no comment and he was
well drilled on it he was well drill not
to term anything I didn't tell him my
name and address I didn't tell him er
like my date of birth I was being as
awkward as I possibly could be and they
let you go
Nellie didn't let me go I didn't know
that was that was when I thought when
you got the five years yes okay yes and
so you were like you were just fresh out
of the game like your your career hadn't
even really quite begun yet no but that
that was the downside to mix him of such
high profile criminals so I was mixing
with criminals that had been doing what
they've been doing for 20-25 years lots
of them have never really been arrested
or they had that Billy had been a person
that point for that 11 years they wasn't
all revolving doors of prisoners in and
out and then that and that it's just
that when they went in they went in for
huge periods of time
and then come back out and just carried
on doing what they did before they went
in there and how often was it getting
violent like how often were the guns
getting discharged and very reading her
very very rare very no no one no one
ever got hurt
in fact like I was again my stepdad
always just say to me when I was young
about you don't need to be violent
towards people it's all about
verbalizing and talking so he was never
like that you would watch a movie a
Hollywood film and everyone's running
around with machine guns letting them
off into the sky and stuff it wasn't
like that at all it was
very controlled very verbalized very
taking control of a situation verbally
letting them know that using control and
people get lost that sometimes getting
because you see these you see these
films and the Prem's cameras than you
watch some people die serve with machine
guns shooting helicopters up and right
actually isn't like that but it wasn't
to the degree with the people that I was
with Joe say what else is the are the
differences between the reality versus
what you see on TV or in the movies
um this world 1:1 like the it isn't sort
of as via light as violent as what is
portrayed to be and you get these
nutcases we'vewe've guns put into
people's heads that that doesn't happen
the drug abuse that side of it that
happens quite prevalent I would say
quite realistic because again you don't
realize this when you're in that world
but I think people were trying to always
escape the reality of what's going to
never ball what's gonna in happen to you
and you're always living in that moment
it's like a form of escapism that you
know eventually he's gonna run its
course yeah that dissonance of like
fronting like it's all gonna be good but
knowing in your unconscious mind
well no it's only a matter of time yeah
and it's never all right you can't help
but everyone that you even if they're
not close to you you're always hearing
about people having their doors kicked
off and the police arrests in them and
someone getting arrested for this
there's always in your subconscious that
these things are going on but you kind
of believe that it's never going to
happen to you but I do think when I look
back now retrospectively that a lot of
the stuff around the drugs and the drink
and the partying all stems back from
that belief that you know eventually
that you're going to end up going down
that same road and well you did you were
you part of that yeah yeah yeah
definitely and again like being a young
man up with my stepdad like it was never
discouraged that never ever ever like I
remember taking young friends out my nut
that they were the same age as me and
there wasn't that many of them but I
remember going out and giving them drugs
and and an offering it to me right and I
was I was 18 yeah
it wasn't that again most fathers
wouldn't do that by their children but
when you're in that life that that
lifestyle a lot of people that is
flagrant disregard like they just don't
care they don't care about anyone really
other than that really tight grouping of
people mm-hmm and where's all the cash
go where you keep where do you use I
mean is it literally under the mattress
or you have places where you're stashing
it or are you laundering it you would be
you'd be surprised by how a lot of
people live when they do that they live
like footballers and it's like a
never-ending well of money so whenever
they you start getting to a degree where
they're getting low they just go and
commit another robbery and they're
stealing like hundreds of thousands of
pounds like they're not beating a couple
of thousands or millions sometimes but
they spend it as fast as it comes in
because he's that high-octane never
ending well with money that's never
gonna and and how do you steer like you
gotta pay like on something you gotta
pay some taxes though right or then you
have problems yeah that way so you get
people setting up a lot of just fine a
lot of stuff with with cash then you
know you get you get that's only gonna
last so long yeah you get a lot of
people that buy a lot of restaurants and
they buy a lot of industry where is a
lot working all there and right yeah and
that there's yeah there's a lot of ways
people get around it like they've closed
all the loopholes off need now but like
people would instance give someone that
owned a property whatever the value of
that property was and give it to in cash
and that would go to a businessman that
then had half a million pound in cash
but he's house didn't really belong to
him anymore it belonged to this criminal
and if the criminal ever needed the
money out of it the guardroom I wish I
had split the money and there was ways
around we're happy people would sort of
circumvents and the money abroad sending
investment people put money into drugs a
lot of robbery money would be invested
in basically of elements of criminal
activity so it's just a never-ending but
it's a lot of work right so it seems
like Oh a part of this robbery girls
money but like there's still a lot of
like that focus like the the level of
like attention you have to pay to all of
those things if it was channeled in a
different direction you know if they
were at Goldman Sachs you know they
could prob
we have the same result yeah yeah I just
just everyday I was I was I was having
this conversation with a friend of mine
and I was saying about like how when you
look alike a lot of people involved in
like drug trafficking and if you got
like a a kilo drugs in South America and
you managed to get that from there and
they're not just one kilo drugs doing
tons across the Atlantic into Europe
without ever sending an email
wherever making a phone call and you've
all created that and then the people are
actively trying to show that you're
linked to it and you're keeping such a
distance and so many people in between
you and that that they can't link that
back the intellect to do that right is
incredible and even I used to get
impressed a bit sometimes I like how
earth-like but you get that from there
to that level of money from one side of
the world to the other and never even
make a phone call or never directly be
linked to it and then you've got
actively people like the DEA and the FBI
serious and organised crime trying to
link you to it and I can't ah right and
they know you involved
oh my god all right so fast forward to
you getting busted and getting the five
years so so yeah I originally I was
charged with nine counts of robbery I
was at the Old Bailey I was 18 years old
what's the old bill so it's like the
highest Criminal Court in the United
Kingdom so he's like the real sort of
yeah you can't leave I'll get Supreme
Court of imagine in America at the
highest court in the land Criminal Court
and I was category a because again they
believed I was such a high risk as a
teenager and that made it quite
exceptional bizarre couldn't be kept
with young offenders so have you're
under 21 you can't be kept with Mal
adults but because I was so high
security I had to be kept with them
because they believed that because my
uncle and my stepdad so I go to call I
was looking at 16 years and I was 18 and
I to me a kid that was I can't even
imagine I can't imagine I'm gonna be in
here for that long and before my trial
was about to commence
I was offered a plea bargain and it was
years must said take it take it because
at that point I'd served the year and he
went you'll do another year and a half -
you're out so I took it
the police livid they were all sitting
in the dock at the Old Bailey I was in
courtroom number one judge Goddard sends
me a lady and and as I was walking down
the police will sitting in the footwell
and I was so arrogant back then and I
looked at him and I said this is [ __ ] in
the shave I'm gonna be out of there and
I was by it's my linen laughing and I
remember as I was walking down the steps
send me back to the cells the prison
officers had took me to the court all
laughing and they said did you see the
looks on their faces and I said yeah and
I was buzzing off it but it didn't
bother again that arrogance they it
didn't bother me and then I went to back
to the prison I was held in and then
that's when I got moved to the prison
where I ended up going into the UM to
that segregation unit where the process
of my training and exercise and really
begun right so the fitness began with
the first set yes yeah
and how long were you in before you
started was so you were in there for a
while you get that you get the solitary
you decide to stay there for a year and
this is where the sauce the salt begins
and then then I got released uh-huh I
come out so you come out looking like a
totally different person like I can be
no one could even really recognize me my
mum I look for me different I went in
there like overweigh come out I just
absent I was very skinny I was I went
down to about 11 stone and none of it
was that some people said I'll need a
land but I felt good and but you I
relapsed so I started going out very
spread that you go to the gym again the
greed it was all about money I was
determined then to make even more money
and before I was locked up and a year
and a half later I get arrested for
conspiracy to commit robbery and like I
said it complete the game completely
changed the second time got the two life
sentences kept in a high security unit
in Belmarsh the minute I was in there I
knew I was gonna be in there for a long
time I knew I wasn't gonna there was no
get out cards there was no plea bargains
there was nothing on the table I was
completely lost no and no smirking in
the courtroom no no [ __ ] in the shape
there was absolutely nothing god I I
knew like my sister on the first legal
visit I said how bad is this
and he went you're 50/50 you're going to
get a life sentence and I said really
and he said yes he said like it's one of
the one of the most shut and cut places
that I've seen with evidence and we kind
of just their nitrous had to accept it
and so when I went back I knew I
couldn't escape because they made that
impossible so again I is how often do
people escape it does happen it does
happen it's very rare but it does happen
maybe one or two a year but normally
it's people getting them out so it'd be
like people going to call and someone
stopping the van on the way to court and
break Wow no in the complex itself not
not so that's very it's quite rare yeah
that's quite rare like then from from
higher security prisons I don't think
anyone managed to break out in the last
like 20 years so is the very sort of
bolt down tight there they've got it and
and they have because believe me when I
was in there like you would look and
there is nowhere to go to life there is
no and I I can concede that point and
yeah and I kind of just had to get my
mindset back into right I'm here I can't
get out I can't break out my friends
can't help me get out how do I get out
of his fast as I can and when you hear a
life sentence or two life sentences that
doesn't mean what you think it means
there's still this this potential
opportunity that you're gonna get a
parole after a number of years so
realistically what did you think you
were looking at I knew what was gonna
get out of my minima Terrace right away
but my mindset back then rich was I
didn't intend to serve that prison
sentence so in my mind when he sentenced
me it meant nothing so people say to me
when I got the sentence and he said life
you'd expect it to have an impact on you
where you'd put huge you shrivel down
and you think oh my God my life's ended
I didn't I listen to it and he meant
nothing I didn't respect the man that
was giving it to me I didn't respect the
place I didn't respect the crown cause
pollution from Crown Prosecution Service
so to me in my mind when I was got that
sentence was
you can give me what you want but
there's no way I'm gonna sit there and
serve that whole sentence and like I
said like I had to think of other ways
that I could go out I knew I couldn't
get out through running for the door
right and it's breaking out they made
that impossible because the level of
security I was on so it was like however
what other ways can I do to get out of
it and it was basically play the system
do what they want me to do so when they
took me back to the prison I said what
of reoffending Haven courses do you want
me to they said we want you to have x
y&z and I said ok they transferred me
out the high security unit they move me
to another maximum-security prison I
turn up there and I did the courses and
in the next year my sent this plan board
what do you want me so it's basically
like we weren't used to this this this
and and you do this thesis and you're
ticking all the boxes and they'd start
downgrading you through the prison
system is it like educational stuff or
what is it exactly it's a mixture so
when you certainly said in this plan
board you'll sit there and they say like
for the next year we want you to get
like enhanced thinking skills we want
you to do a victim awareness course and
we want you to do your English and maps
like jesus' and you do that and the
following year they say we want you to
not do this course who and what you do
like your a-levels and english your maps
and you do that and then what happens as
you go through here on year on year you
basically take all these boxes and then
when you go on your parole hearing he
says that you've done everything they've
want he's used oh it becomes impossible
for the parole board to say we're not
gonna let you out as long as you've not
been violent in prison you're not being
violent full staff and other inmates but
again I didn't even think that I would
even I had no interest in going to a
parole board right my thing was I just
needed to get this maximum-security
prison so and it happened it worked
after two years they downgraded me to a
category B prison and I think I'm out
like this is my release that I'm nearly
out now they transferred me to this open
like this category B prison and I can't
explain the difference in security is
huge like I went from being on this tiny
little wing in this maximum security
prison in on your chair up north to this
prison where it was so open there was
not that many prison officers walking
around it was very sort of relaxed and I
got there straight away you know people
that know people and said anyone got a
mobile phone people have mobile phones
and you're not allowed
I'm obviously I got found I found out my
friends that lived in the Netherlands my
best friend Alan and I said to him I've
just got transferred here and stuff and
shout aways first thing was tell me when
the first opportunity you get to go we
get you out and and I know it sounds
like a film but this is how my mindset
yeah then I might when my uncle was in
prison when I was a kid they tried to
break him out of a helicopter like so so
this was always in my psychology I knew
these things were possibility yeah so
when I'm in access to the phones I mean
regular contact my friends in Holland
and Spain and it was all about first
opportunity wait and I was okay let me
just see how things are going to shape
up and in 2009 my life changed forever
when I found out my friend that I was on
the phone to all the time Aaron had died
to commit a robbery in the Netherlands
and and that was the catalyst for for me
being a different person
mm-hmm was there like an initial sense
of like hopelessness or what was it
exactly that shifted before you start to
channel that into a positive direction I
remember like that stuff people dying
people getting murdered people getting
stabbed shot like it never happened to
me that bad stuff happened to other
people and I would talk to my friends
and someone said guess what happens to
sob blah blah or so and so so I was just
from a young person that I was always
hearing about these things that were
going on that never happens to me me and
my friends were good like Urim you and
your poor prove me that doesn't happen
even I was in prison you're smart at
this yeah you you don't anticipate that
one day that other person's gonna be
someone that you love and care for so
when that happened to him I can remember
when I was I was in disbelief and I've
ever sitting in his prison cell and I
was in complete disbelief or I couldn't
actually compute he was dead and in the
following evening on the nose on channel
3 because it was so rare that these
English criminals were committing crime
abroad in the Netherlands it made news
at 10 it was our primetime news and I
sitting in his prison cell watching my
prison TV and my friend run up to the
CCTV camera and spray the can of spray
into the lens and the camera froze
literally before he sprayed it and and I
know it was my friend I could tell by
his eyes I could see it was him and I
remember sitting in that cell watching
the last moments of his life and in
their camera crude and cutaway to the
car cuz as they were getting away the
car tire blew out the car fleeing my
mate got thrown out the car and the car
was just a crumpled mess on the side of
this Dutch motorway and I remember
sitting in that cell and and I looked at
my life and I realized that precious
life is like that should have been me in
that car I should have been that person
I was the one that need got shot by the
police two times I was the one that had
the mad car chases new place I was the
one that Drive guns up and that my
friend didn't my friend got unlucky one
night never been in trouble with the
police in his life he commits the crime
of a group of people and one night that
cost him his life and then I looked at
my life in that place and everything
that I was brought up to believe in
about the system money was everything it
wasn't and I felt embarrassed it was
pathetic right I looked in my life in
that prison cell and I had a 16,000
pound gold gold Rolex watch on my wrist
in prison in prison no because again it
was it was how arrogant I was because to
me that was a demonstration an
expression that even though you've put
me in here
I've still got money and you can't take
that off me and you can't change me and
subconsciously again it was that
expression of of power over the system
it wasn't about me chatting to the
working man [ __ ] you like you've got no
money or anything it was about me
demonstrating to the system that I've
got these nice things and you can't do
nothing and again it is it was it was
controlling and I looked apathetic it
wasn't all of these men have grown up as
a kid that I looked up to and they were
my heroes they were all old men sitting
in prison or they were dead and my
friend just lost his life and I knew
from that moment that that was me done I
honestly like I can't express it in two
words it was like someone switched on
the light in my head and I had this
awareness of our precious your life is
as you
and the next morning I went down for
breakfast in the communion area and
there was all these guys and they were
talking about when they got out they was
gonna do this and that and this person
was an informer and he was a grass and
he was gonna do this and that and I
thought I can't be around these people
no more I can't listen to this rubbish
and the only way I can explain it is
like if he was a drug addict and you
wanted to get off drugs but he was
locked in a crack then around drug
addicts and you're trying to get off and
I needed
I wasn't fortunate where I couldn't get
up and walk out at that place I was
trapped physically so I and I had to
then develop a way of a form of escapism
to take me out of that world like take
me out not just prison physically but
mentally mm-hmm and that when training
took on a far greater significance to me
and exercise so did you then resume that
like diligent you know protocol of the
push-ups and the sit-ups and the step
ups and all of that or was there was
there the rowing machine there and you
just said okay I'm gonna try this so
like what was when you're in prison you
get limited to the amount of gym access
that you can have and I answer you Jim
your wing gets Jim certain times a week
that's it so you get free gym sessions a
week on your wing and he's to stop you
for meeting people in different wings
case of fights and stuff and when I went
down the gym there was this guy on the
rowing machine and he was down at every
session I was on and he wasn't on my
wing and I went up to him and I said
what are you doing and he said I'm
writing this million meters for a
Children's Hospice and I said what and
they let you have as much Tim as you
want he said yes so I went to the prison
officer dove works in the gym and I said
can I do what he's doing and he said if
you go back up on the wing response ship
forms and the prison sponsor you come
back down give it to us you can row and
raise money for children for the
Children's Jerry so I went I went and
did it come back gave him the Schultz
and the EE performs and he gave me a
dispensation now so it's allowed me to
get off the wings go down the gym as
much as I wanted to her so it was - Ryan
million meters and you could roll it 5k
a 10k 20k that however he went to write
got on the round machine first session
not done at 26 was 20 miles
so I read 32,000 years and when I did it
I
in another world and I mean that like
people left me alone prisoners didn't
talk to me prison officers didn't talk
to me and I remember looking at this
little monitor in this prison gym and I
could have been anywhere in the world
and I just honestly was like the only is
the nearest I could say it was like
meditation it was a forum it genuinely
was like a forum he transcended me at
present I could have been anywhere in
the world and obviously I didn't
understand about endorphins I didn't
understand about that but that was
obviously what was happening I did it
the next day I went down 42,000 meters
next day for active as meters and
they're not just it become a compulsive
to go down and keep doing the same
distance I did the first million meters
a thousand care in a month and then I
thought I can keep doing this and this
is gonna help me get through my prison
sentence so I asked if I could do
another million I said yes
did that did the third million free
months mm-hmm then the prisoner went to
me you know five million meters that's
equivalent from where from Britain to
the America so it's equivalent to the
Atlantic so I asked a prison officer I
said look can I just throw the extra two
million and it is cool things to say
that I've read a person lately but
really it was because it kept me in the
gym for two more months as I was getting
through the fourth million I woke up an
ability in my body that I never knew I
even had I'm in this little bubble in a
prison you you're not in the real world
you're in this cocoon you don't know
what Fitness is you don't you just
walked I've never been against athletes
I didn't know what was good what was bad
I just knew in prison on this Ram
machine I could hold better numbers than
Bob next to me and the prison officer
Darren Davis walked behind me one day
and he looks over my shoulder and he
went wow he went that is is quick and he
left and in a couple of days later he
came back we've all of these sheets of
paper and I had all the world and
British Records on the indoor rowing
machine uh-huh and he gave him to me and
honestly rich at that moment I remember
looking at this list and I was like I
can break some of them records now and I
didn't think they were real
I generally didn't and I welcome this
this physical ability I never I never
knew I had I was good at endurance sport
and I never realized it and it planted
the seed and I went back to my cell and
I come back and I said can I do this can
I try spray some of his records he went
to a man called Garrison's
and garrisons was the governor of this
prison he was a deeply religious man
like really really religious and down
when this got prisoner John he he wants
to do so his life he wants to change and
I believe this could help him will you
let him try to break these records from
prison aha and I don't want to interrupt
you but had you voiced your desire to
transcend your criminal upbringing and
change your life or were you just sort
of quietly you know hitting the ERG
every day had you told this guard like
look man I really know I never had I
never I never had that conversation with
him because again no I he could just see
it and yes that he could sense of
physical billy and nothing he could
sense that i was a good guy I was in I
wasn't a horrible I do our treaty to
people in prison even to the regard that
you have a week like I can t remember
this a guy on Instagram comment on one
of my photos and add vet this I've read
the message and I met this guy he was in
prison with me I can't remember meeting
him and he was like I remember the
impact you out of my life when he was in
prison and he was on the RAM machine he
was encouraging me and he went you made
me feel so special and it helped me
better my life and I I can't remember
but that's what I mean again I wasn't a
bully I wasn't a horrible person and I
think Darren could see that in me and he
saw that I was good and he thought this
guy could do something here so he went
around the government proved it so
Darren a lot of the prison officers
they're not so sort of they're not so
open-minded and start and let's try to
take you down a peg a lot of them don't
want to this a lot of them then didn't
want to I don't know view it might be
not when you to succeed but Darren did
so Darren had to come in when he's days
off so he wouldn't be in paid by the
prison to sit with me to basically
validate the record so and they dare to
set a camera up there to put a special
chip card in the RAM machine to pull the
data wrong and take photographs and film
it
so the first record I broke was for the
marathon and I broke it by seven minutes
and some marathon 26.2 miles yes right
on Endora
right British record British British
record right you broke it by seven
minutes seven minutes above us right for
hitting your first attempt first attempt
uh-huh and I'm even to the gray I can
remember so when we when when I did it
like I can't tell you my lack of
knowledge on nutrition like a surgeon
sugar energy drink but I did I didn't
have access to it for a start so I
didn't have gels or any of that sort of
stuff
uh-huh it was only my basic knowledge so
when I was doing the record I promised
you a prisoner had to go and get me a
satchel of these like sugars and I was
putting raw sugar in my mouth from
drinking water right like what you would
put in your coffee yes that's on my foot
and his energy and obviously I eat it I
made me start feeling sick and sup it
just the bat got me through it uh-huh
and I remember when I broke that record
I was lying on the gym mat after and I
remember feeling this overwhelming sense
of achievement and and everything I'd
ever want it as a young kid to be better
than average to achieve sank my life to
leave a legacy I felt everything I could
do it through that through sport and I
could use my Vig my body as a vehicle to
get me out of that world and not only
that but be successful and this was the
thing I could do to find that success
then from that moment I become obsessed
we've been an athlete like to the degree
where I'd go down to a library every
Friday and I used to get the librarian
she had two older books in from the
outside library into the lie because
obviously there wasn't that many
prisoners interested in sports nutrition
and training and stuff so she would
ascend to get these orders and bring
them in and I have a week I'd read read
read read read and I'll start to
understand about physiology or stunts
understand about sports nutrition
they're not started reading all these
books Lance Armstrong's book all these
Olympic rowers
what year is this this was in 2009 and I
started reading all these
autobiographies of all these athletes
and I was like I've got these categories
so I can be successful and then from
that moment my dream in prison was being
an athlete that was it within 16 months
I'd set eight British record
and free world records on the indoor
rowing machine and I was at one point
was the only lightweight man in the
world to have all three ultra endurance
World Records at simultaneously at one
point and and that was it I knew that I
had disability then and and down and
said it's me when you've got the ability
not that you're fit but you have the
ability that you can suffer and even if
you come out of prison and you waste
that gift it will be the biggest
travesty that I've ever seen as a prison
officer and those words to this day
stick with me in my mind every single
time I race in that Ironman on that
Marvin I'm trying to imagine how this
must have shook up the rowing community
I mean did this make news what you were
doing this I'm just I'm picturing like
the guys at Oxford and Cambridge who are
getting the printout what do you mean
what's this guy like he's in prison he
brought these World Records like what's
going on here you know what you'll be
very surprised he actually didn't I am a
reason it didn't so when the when the
records went on the system they wasn't
being put down I was a prisoner they
were just put in my name
and and I was in Nottingham um so there
was none of that sort of fanfare around
it right
the only time right again it seems very
cinematic I broke the world record for
the most amount of distance rode in 24
hours on the indoor air machine and I
wrote 265 thousand meters in 24 hours
and I remember Darren said start a
record at four o'clock in the afternoon
and in your finish at four o'clock the
next day in the afternoon because in
that way you'll be able to go to bed
that night and you ought your your body
clocks not gonna be all that synced and
I remember I went back on the wing the
following morning I broke that world
record by 13 miles and when I went on it
even says adapt and remember it they
open up the gates on this wing and I
walked on and all of the prisoners were
being kept aware of what I was doing
there kept tense a prison officers easy
broken it is he nearly gonna break it
and what happened when I was in prison I
become a bit of a champion because I was
competing against people outside and so
the prisoners in prison wanted me to do
it yeah well it meets of course right
yeah yeah and I remember walking on and
these prisoners were on the landings and
I was all clapping that I come on and I
broke this record
and I felt I remember film that I felt
shattered but I felt amazing life--all
Wow light I've just achieved so amazing
and and I've hadn't that sort of impact
all these people wanted me to do it and
it was an incredible feeling and and
it's it's only since sight since I've
been out I've gone back to that prison
and they've got like pictures of when I
broke the records I'm in the gym and it
is absolutely incredible like to know
that you can plant those seeds in other
people's heads to show them what you can
do if you like but the air that that was
it was amazing but then it did start
becoming really frustrating when I
couldn't get out mm-hmm I broke all the
records I could break there was none
left for me too though uh-huh I realized
that this physical potential I was young
I was strong I was the fittest or
fittest roaming fears I've ever been in
my life but I was trapped in prison and
I couldn't get out I was doing these
life sentences and I remember I went for
a real sort of stage where it becomes so
frustrating to me like I knew I changed
I was demonstrating it I broke all these
records and and people saying how
amazing it was and but they wouldn't let
me out mm-hmm because I still had year a
year left to serve my prison sentence
and that got delayed because they they
sort of made mistake bureaucratic
mistakes and that led to me and not
being in their free years over what I
originally be sentenced though so when
did you eventually get out and how did
that work
so my first parole hearing we sat there
and I had to get in front released in
front of a crown called judge yet to
come in and what year is this this was
in the first hit of 2011 uh-huh and I
remember so you get your krinkle judge
retired he sits in Franklin it's a
typical parole here now you can imagine
that you got you judge in front of you
direct in front of you you've got to his
left the layperson member of the public
got criminal psychologist
you got your probation officer sitting
next you in your solicitors in the next
year and the judge meant to me what are
you what you really spend so I said I'm
gonna be a professional athlete and he'd
certainly sat back in his chair and
smile at me and he leant for and he went
I have never heard a prisoner seen from
8:00
but I I which I absolutely believe that
I don't know you might think I'm making
this up oh no I don't think you're
babies and you just broke three world
records you didn't break him you crush
them it was without knowing anything
really even about the sport and having
never been in a boat and and having not
grown up as an athlete I believe you it
was like any smart any man I've known
said when I've never heard a prisoner
ever come and say that in all the years
I've set life centers or parole hearings
so I had a criminal psychologist that
does reports when you're in prison
and he looked to him and he went what
we're seeing today would you say this is
all smoke and mirrors and the criminal
psychologist in British prisons they're
not aureus that people often say a swoop
of a pen can keep you in prison for
years if they believes that the diagnose
if you got an underlying psychological
disorder so sociopath or psychopath if
you are you're my service to the public
and obviously then you're probably never
going to get in till you've gone for all
these special courses that they want you
to do and I thought oh my god he's not
pleased yeah and actually the the
psychologist said to him if he he's gone
well beyond what he would have had to
have done to try to pull the wool over
your eyes he went like he could have
just done a couple level three gym
instructor courses and Satyam said the
same thing he meant but the stuff he's
done
you could not like like zoom out there
the longest continuous row in those
things he went you physically couldn't
do it unless he deeply deeply had a
desire to do it so the judge basically
asked me to leave the room I went back
in and they didn't release me they what
they'd done I get it even I don't think
your release plans based in reality he
went but I'm gonna move you to a
semi-open prison so we can slowly
integrate you back into society so they
moved me to an open prison where I was
able to go out every damn work
voluntarily in Enid Fitness first gym
it's like a halfway house yeah basically
he's still you're still in prison but it
all works on trust so I mean what if you
left and didn't want to go back you
didn't have to but it did it RINs a
great amount in society I got used to
working I never had a job in my life I
started working as a personal trainer in
this
Jim in his little village up north and
yeah and I was there for a year and a
bit and then I end up getting released
in 2012 after the Olympics
I'll get released a Google
high-performance rowing clubs in London
and this london rowing club comes up
near partner in southwest London and it
was like a feeder system into the GB set
up yeah so I go down there and just to
give people a bit of an understanding
physiologically from my weight for a
lightweight man I was putting out the
same so you get you to K then your 5k in
rowing those numbers mean everything
that that is it
so there's minimum requirements that you
have to pull on a rowing machine to even
be looked at to become an international
rower if you don't pull those numbers
you only me looked at they won't even
watch you around the water so my 2000
meter time was 14 seconds faster what
you would have needed to get into the
International GB squad and on my 5k it
was I think it was like 38 seconds
faster so aerobically I was much
stronger over 5k but the problem that I
had that I soon realized was rowing is
such a technical sport that in rowing
new classes a veteran or 26 yeah I took
it up of 29 I was nearly 30 and I
realized quite soon I couldn't get to
that level in rouen but I wanted to as
an athlete right so I had to make a
tough decision after four months that
this isn't gonna work this isn't going
to facilitate me doing what I want to do
so I had to basically I looked around
and when I was in prison I I saw this
episode of transport support and there
was a show called Ironman or a sport it
was an Ironman shared within it and I
remember watching Kona and and I just
remember feeling these men are dead it's
incredible like watching him get off
bikes and running like
two-and-a-half-hour fans and it inspired
me when I was in prison and then when I
knew it I couldn't become a professional
athlete being a rower I went on google
google to criteria and I fall right I'm
gonna go and do Ironman I went off on
eBay and I bought bike dad said I've
never ridden the bike I was in 30 yeah I
taught myself to swim off YouTube videos
never swam never ever ever like
even when I was out of prison you might
have caught me in a say bobbing around
like when I was on holiday but no
swimming nothing
so I basically taught myself to swim and
the only race I could do was Ironman UK
because I wasn't allowed to leave the
United Kingdom and Ironman UK was in six
weeks time after I decided that I went
to the Ironman
so that was browsing a sergeant for what
a gun and deep end so I go into I am an
UK tribesman at the race sold out so I
had to go and get a charity ballot place
and get into our man UK six weeks later
so the furthest I'd ever swum was there
the race the furthest I've ever cycled
was there the race but I'd run like I'd
run further than that before longer than
the marathon you had run longer than a
marathon yeah like so I probably I
should have probably mentioned this
earlier on so when I was in the open
prison I decided to run an ultra
marathon because I was willing to test
my body always a different challenge hmm
so the governor there there was the gym
instructors in the prison there was a
couple of enriched like in the role Navy
and then my neighbor totoro neighbor
they can't work in the Prison Service
and obviously they knew I was his really
fit guy come there brave I broke all
these records sort of my reputation tour
procedure before got to prison so all
these prison officer like this head guy
that's broke all these prisoners and
obviously bit of banter and stuff like
that and one of them start talking about
ultra marathon running and I was all
right what is it and said anything over
a man for this officer I'll go man when
I was working out in the gym I used to
go to the library in the village before
I would go to the gym to work every
morning side there were half-hour
windows to get the bus half hour goes to
this library Guarnere ultramarathons
there is an ultramarathon from London to
Brighton which was like 56 miles long
and I went to prison I said look
drinking there let me out to do it so
forgot for the weekend so they go away
governor says you could do it so the
only run in I had ever done was on a
treadmill in the prison gym furthest
I've ever run was 10k on the treadmill
and a next thing you know they give me
the snow to start the London to Brighton
Old Trafford
so they let me out I'll go down to black
K for the London Marathon starts and
literally you run from there so trowel
mouth and down to the coast and and it
was probably as I said because it'll
never run one of the hardest things
by the thing I never done night I
remember my legs my quads after I
finished I finished it yeah I did it I
did it 12 hours of did it huh
and then I remember like when I was
running down the hills I had to run
backwards because my quads gone and then
i paralyzed myself afterwards I've got
the taxi coming back and I remember the
taxi driver who dropped me back from
Bryant and back to London and he didn't
want to take the money he went I cannot
believe you run from the printer right
and I walk back to the prison all my
legs were bruised that world swelling
come out but yeah it's amazing it was
amazing like 1 million percent when I've
finished with Ironman I all hundred
percent through ultra marathon a night
to me it is it is amazing like the way
you feel is so much higher than Ironman
so so so so much hard my man
psychologically I feel like it's more
challenging physically his channel is
harder but I love running I love it I
found out when I run now like I love I
don't like running with other people I
like running on my own it's like a form
of meditation I can me I find it really
hard to relax but I'm always thinking
about stuff like when I go riding my
bike I'm always thinking about things to
swim I'm always think I can't switch off
but when I run just switch off I could
be anywhere in the world again and it is
near if not more than when I sit on a
tram machine from 10k being your longest
run on a treadmill not even running 10k
like on roads or trails to running 56
miles I'm still like picturing we've
kind of put rowing in the rear view but
you kind of rolling up on this
you know semi elite rowing club having
never been in a boat before and saying
oh yeah here here's my here you can look
at these numbers you know and they're
faster than probably most of the guys in
the club right like who is this guy the
one of the first gestures are done so I
I got released from prison on a Friday
Saturday morning I go down to the club
the head coach ever strangle you yeah
yeah I emailed him for a come down or
selling it so he was aware I was gonna
turn up they did not take novice rowers
but he said to me what was she took a
time
so told him and even taught that that's
good and he was I and he he had this
philosophy and he said all the time you
can't coach what God's given you and he
for a used to say to me if you've got a
big engine
you can't some people that just happen
and you can coach that big engine to row
well and that's all you need to do
that's my job
so you I know you've got the raw power
and it's my job to teach where to use
that power on a boat baby you haven't
got that power doesn't matter how much
you take it good the guy with a bigger
engine will always beat you when he
learns to get that sort of there's a
technical element but the problem is you
just needed to get in a boat as a much
younger person yes I is the same with
swimming it's really hard to learn
swimming yeah you know older when you're
older you know and in your later years
it's just something that you can pick up
quite easily if you're in the right
environment and touch it but like trying
to even learn to run you can learn to
ride a bike but like swimming it's it's
it's a holding and you see it when you
see people like come across from doing
like your money back transients or
Ironman but they get to a point where
they just don't progress and the people
that like those low 50 sub 50 minutes
Rimmer's you tend to find come from
swimming backgrounds that have spun the
whole lives and right to them pumping
out those sort of times is it really a
challenge where like the other guys they
like try and just get under the hour and
stuff yeah and they're expending a lot
more energy because it because the
people who really know how to swim know
how to make the water work for them so
there's so much more efficient and their
output is is de minimis compared to the
guy who's you know just slashing the
water may yeah so how did that first
Ironman go I mean six weeks like there's
only so much you can do in six weeks yes
especially when you don't know how to
swim
so like the guys there's a couple of
guys at the rowing club that like where
they're just recreation and we were
chatting about it and one of them said
to me he said look there's no point you
going out do a massive bike rides now
because you've never ridden a bike you
probably get injured so you imagine just
ride the distance in the race so it was
it it was it was I when I race I put
that I've I see this as an athlete so I
have nearly been killed two times right
literally been to the point where I'm
fractions of inches away from
policemen shoot me dead in the big
picture of things in life but I've never
lost my life so I look at everything
like that through that lens so there's a
really doing a rector in the swim and
Ironman it's not me that big of a deal
while getting on a bike ride a bike like
it's just physical activity exact
exercises there's no real greater
significance other than that I'm not
going to lose my life doing it and I
just put everything into relative terms
of light when I've had my life taken off
me for ten years
fasting back that that's stress that's a
lot of stress to go through like when
when you're an Ironman I see that as
some privilege I'm there that morning
I'm physically able to do it one day I
won't be able to light and the eye I see
is a massive honor and privilege to be
there and be able to physically do it
and compete it and I did that morning I
turn up I didn't have any fear
whatsoever an awful just experience in
to see what it's like and you know what
the only thing that I really got from it
but man it was amazing when I finished
it right to watch that TV show on Prison
and in be there and actually do it and
run down that red carpet was it was
incredible but it was when I was on the
bike one of the pro guys went past me
and even though I had never was even
that thought he lapped me because it was
like free loops in the same circuit and
I thought that will never happen to me
again in an Ironman race I remember that
and and that day those were the things
that really stuck with me and I finished
the race and an awful right I didn't
honestly which I didn't feel that touch
by I didn't feel I felt comfortable I
felt I was removing myself like I didn't
I didn't feel like I was gonna blow up
I wasn't massively quick like I am a new
place quite hilly and I did it a night
11 and a half hours and so I finished
offing 100 fat about three and a
thousand people about eleven and a half
in six weeks without knowing how to swim
and having never really liked but it was
a B and they're not for what this is
this is what I'm gonna do this is it and
and then I started um I made a lot of I
made a lot of errors then because then I
thought he was too easy and I thought I
would train how I trained on a round
machine in prison the same Ironman so I
went from basically never really been a
runner to running nearly a mouth and
every Saturday Sunday morning around
Battersea Park within
eight weeks I could come free runs up
for our muffins it wasn't hard it was I
remember and what happened it become
very addictive because I was talking to
guys and they like they're talking about
like running us up three at London was
Indian that's not hard but I can do that
in training I do it all the time I'll do
it every Saturday and and I got quicker
and quicker and quicker and the same
thing bike I was riding indoor bikes
what bites and in a rowing club my what
just got bigger and bigger and because I
kept training as hard as I could
every session cuz the suffering and
you're just you're freewheeling it
though like you're not working no coach
no nothing and again that was something
this is someone was stuck with me from
being a care of distrust the high fall
to myself there and this is my goal this
is my dream not someone else's and I
don't trust anyone else with this and
and I thought I knew better I thought
that I could do this myself and and as I
said I dug myself into the biggest hole
liar I was sweating I was waking up in
the early morning I was getting up early
and then to me then it become how much
do I lie even though I feel like crap
I'm just gonna go out and just keep
hammering it and I'm only hammer it and
and again I just kept digging this hole
and I was getting quicker but my body
wasn't recovering it was breaking down
and breaking down and then I end up
really getting sick I started on I've
been on a training camp and I'm in went
for a swim one morning and I couldn't
breathe
for what that I've never felt anything I
could not breathe physically breathe
I've got out of water and then later on
that day I was in the car couldn't
breathe again
and obviously I was having like a panic
attack where I was draining the life out
my body got a virus then went back to
why man you lady the the following year
and just absolutely fell apart
it was the most humiliated I'd ever felt
in my life
I felt worse that day than I ever did
being in any of those courts getting
that life sentence I I felt ashamed I
all my friends I took back Terry come up
my really close friend and Darren the
prison officer come up and I remember
like then being on the side of the
course I feel I let everyone down they
put a lot of time and and I come away
from that race and I realized I didn't
have the skills to coach myself or the
humility yeah you know the humility is
the big lesson they're going from this
stubborn guy who thinks he knows better
you can't be a great athlete without the
humility to be able to take direction
from people who want to help you totally
you know I know I had to realize that
but I had to realize it in that moment
that had to happen to me that had to
hurt yeah otherwise you were unteachable
Yeah right silently so your most
impressive world record is perhaps a
world record from going from complete
novice to over trained in the shortest
period of time yeah Mike yeah from night
literally zero hours for Ironman trade
it's like 35 40 hours a week I've just
yeah just as hard as I could do it right
that was all body can't absorb but that
quickly but I thought he could yeah and
I and again I thought he could because I
was thinking about 2 hours a day every
day in prison on a rowing machine I
remember like some of those sessions
when I was in prison on those drownings
and I got to like a couple million
meters every day like there's no rest
days and my hand
Ted those like the tens my hand coming
off a crawl and I you could unclick my
fingers so I had no I had that
propensity to push myself that hard
right and to me that suffering of
getting up in the morning feeling like
crap because I was overtraining was to
me an expression of how much I wanted
this goal because it was I I can suffer
more than other people and that really
become my Achilles tendon but it was the
best thing that and to me falling apart
that day yeah better than then now yeah
right
so must've taken you a while to climb
out of that Hall yeah I just go to a
hospital or now these XI G's done to
make sure I didn't miss my heart I just
had a real pop I roll fatigue I was very
fortunate that my body did kind of over
in a couple of months like I didn't stop
training completely by completely backed
off like I still the only staff not
exercised for him since 26 years old odd
2025 was probably last year and I had 12
days off completely done literally no
exercise and that was he's such an
ingrained part of me I couldn't ever
imagine not being physically active I'm
just doing something even that means me
getting up and going for like a 10k run
or something like that like in that was
but I've learned that's what me I've
learned about my body I've learnt I need
to do that I can't
Tricia's I get a bit older I can't keep
talk about going to the world all the
time and put in the bucket down and I'm
trying to just absorb loads and loads
loads a load I have to be a bit more
intelligent of stuff yeah I mean that's
that's quite the arc like if you go to
your website like right there on the
homepage it's like you have all the
people that you know comprise your team
that are helping you so from that guy
who's so stubborn who thinks he knows
everything and won't let anybody tell
him anything to having you know what I
saw when I looked at your website I was
like oh that's that's humility like he
understands that this is a team effort
and that you can't do what you do alone
we have Terry here who I mean is this
around the time where Terry you know
comes into your life no Terry come into
my life well Terry come into my life
when I was working in the gym someone
was working part-time Terry was a member
and a gym instructor that was held up
work with Terry sometimes doing massage
with him come up to me one day to see
that guy up there he's a sports
psychologist and all I heard was sport
so even our introduces Terry's Altos on
them like Oh a treadmill and I've gone
up and I've just introduced myself and I
think Terry for who is this guy
and obviously we sat down and I told
Terry my backstory and go with the crazy
eyes and stuff and and we just struck up
this friendship and Terry was like he
just paid an interest in me and that
that he wanted to help me and again
there was no agenda and then when I
still get out on a Sunday I was so far
from London because I was I was up in a
neat just outside Darby which is about
200 miles away so I couldn't commute to
London go back up with my you get like
something like for a town visit you'd be
out of prison for 12 hours and Terry
Minter used to go out for dinner or
lunch you know in the local town they
were taking out for Sunday dinner and
we'd sit there and we talked about
staffing and then he was really just
part of my journey ever ever since and
Terry was one of the first people I
would say that I really really did trust
like I've really open up and I'm
everything that I've gotten in to do
with my life like without him being part
of it it wouldn't be where it is today
he's been he's been he's been the
massive part a role of what I do and
again you he doesn't matter how driven
and focused you are you need good people
around you to help you reach your
potential in life and it works both ways
I'm sure Terry's lying
from the experiences of we've been
thrown and vice versa
I mean it's been amazing to share it
with someone else as well right right
right right and then you bring on
somebody who's triathlon specific yeah
yeah
and then he's been yeah the physical
element of it right so we did some
training sessions before that Ironman I
fell apart and he knew how fit I was
because he saw through some of the
training stuff that we were doing
together and then when we did Ironman UK
he finished fourth fifth overall and and
I finished like a hundred and he went
that I even passed me and I was walking
on the map and he you had your way yeah
now we know what happens when you do it
your way
and even actually do it my way he
reached out to me and he said look I'll
coach you for free I just want to help
you just be the best athlete you can be
and I've been working with him for the
last sort of free--free in a bit yes
mm-hmm
so then when was your big breakthrough
race probably Frankfurt yeah that was
quite a step up right and you went nine
or some nine nine nine nine even yeah
like again anyway I'm always learning
the bike has really been the thing I've
been learning the most like the running
for instance is like my Ironman my fans
like three hours I can get off and
running through our mouths and huh
fairly comfortable like it's not really
a push but the bikes been the thing
where it's not been the power it's been
that just the the lack of riding years
and that my taking corners too wide
breaking too much and that starts adding
up a lot over a hundred and eighty K and
then sometimes I've looked at races
where guys that I make my weight I'm
putting out similar numbers or I'm
putting out and they're like 15 minutes
at the road for me and you know you
can't give that sort of time away yeah
you're not you're you have to learn how
to translate that engine that they have
into speed and it's an E and it is
coming hopefully it comes in freestyle
yeah I mean do you live in London proper
yeah you do so where do you go to train
and do your long rides and so I'll go
out to light winds up so after you leave
when you leave mind we've got like 20
minute a bit of a faff with traffic and
stuff and then it's kind of just flat
fast roads going out to Windsor Castle
or you've got the Surrey Hills again
it's number 15 20 minutes getting out
and then you get clear roads around that
all around the Surrey Hills up which is
quite nice
running retro and park down the towpath
that's one of my favorite runs the old
way down a tough like you could run from
you can run from basically Putney
southwest London all the way up to
Thames there's actually an ultra map and
attends 100 he's just up the side of the
soap off alright right cool
and in the swimming you do there is a
pool where you get out no water or
you've got the serpentine right um yeah
almost avatar my just swimming leidos
there's quite a few of them dotted round
London and you train alone what's the
community like here um quite good
southwest London you tend to find a lot
of guys at Kona the Brownlee's live in
town here now Tate they live up in Leeds
it is they're northerners but a lot of
him dancin border yep timber yeah but a
lot of the um I think he's been tricking
my originally he's usually grew up
that's not that's not too far away from
Richmond it's about 15 minutes away but
a lot of really good Ironman triathlete
actually live round southwest London so
a lot of buyers a very very good age
groupers that are based that way so you
do get some decent guys going out but I
do train on my own a lot yeah you strike
me as there you're a lone wolf yeah I
don't I go I do go out riding sometimes
with people and I think why have I done
this mm-hmm
it's different if you got like I got
sometimes it's hard sometimes because
I've got regards that row and now I'm
very very fit but then they want to push
the pace too much in each two two
together discipline is you got a you got
to do what what you got to fulfill the
intention for that work yes and when
you're training for Ironman or ultra
endurance a lot of that discipline plays
into holding back yet right yeah cuz
everyone it's you know there's a
dick-measuring contest high wave and
everyone would see how quick they can go
up a client and then they all blow up
and then you're all sort of then limping
back coming in like to have a week I've
invited my friend to my not to Henley
it's a hundred mile ride and I said are
you are you sure you want to comment
yeah yeah certainly will so I said okay
so we were averaging like 35 K an hour
and he's on the back wheel and we got to
start open stretcher road and he's come
out behind me about 60 counts of riot or
off right and I for what I do I'll just
keeping
ten-minute gap just do a bit of
practicing so I'm not drafting his a bit
of I'm and work and he's looking behind
and he thinks she's dropped me and I'm
thinking oh I think yeah he's thinking
on it and you I can tell you thinks I've
dropped it off or what I'm just gonna
have to let him see now so I've come up
into his world close the gap and then
just tour around and gone yeah and he's
like wow like he can't you weren't
supposed to Dell wasn't part of what you
were she wasn't doing that word I can't
help it but I did what happened to him
when we were coming back
he was quite turned when I looked at him
and he started going like June she's so
I'm gonna ash white and I said you're
right he's like yeah I mean you know I'm
not even I really feel bad can we stop
and get a mars bar and we used to be had
two privates inside shop and he he got
that so that's probably a lot of the
reasons why I don't like training other
people well here you are today and you
have fulfilled this promise this
aspiration that you articulated to the
parole board of being a professional
athlete I mean you are a professional
athlete you're a Nike sponsored athlete
you're the only triathlete that Nike
Simon's right Ironman triathlete wow man
how did that come together um how can I
put this rich it was like it was like it
was like a fairy tale
it was I honestly thought it was one of
the biggest things in my life my honour
unlike as an achiever Knight but a man
that was in prison at fight 26 this had
want to be a professional athlete
people laughed that people said you
never had to do it to cop sports lady
you're never there when you got a prison
your prisoner your rear end it was hard
leaning out like you'll never have to do
that like you're just slipping to all
crowds and your salt get involved in
robberies and that'd me and then but a
prison overtrained
cause sick made decisions get a coach
carried on it believed in every day I
honestly there's one thing i i've
visualized and believed every day
everything I was doing would pay off I I
knew it I knew it I didn't know what
would be and I just what does that
knowingness come from self belief I
always believed whatever I put my mind
that I I believed when I was a kid that
I'd be a multi-millionaire I believed I
on it I just always had it in me this
intrinsic finger it's just overwhelming
need to want to do showing great
with my life from being a young kid and
that's that belief that I could do it
I'm never that belief like my mom said
this to me recently she said even when I
was little she would take me to our
summer camp and all of these kids would
be in a corner and it all be like
looking around and never know what to do
and I'll jerk off with my arm and do it
so like these rock climbing everyone's a
beautiful thing I've put a ring on and
on to climb the wall and then sometimes
an input safety on something to go man
but I've always had that in me like I
would always be very certain about bang
I'm gonna do it and do it from being a
young boy and and I had that belief and
I remember I was at a prison for two
years I over trained and I was around my
mum's one day and and I remember like I
feel more about it and I said like I
can't I can not and will not give up on
this and I had the CCG box on my heart
from the hospital bed when it's morning
for 24 hours and I know mum it will pay
off and my mum said just carry on doing
what you're doing and follow you dream
do not stop and and I didn't and I went
up and I raised again the following year
and I'd a much better result and then
last the Christmas before last Terry
there was obviously been massive part of
my life he acts as a bit of a firewall
he runs my web site and every day we
bring each other up in the morning and
he says these are the emails that have
come through last night or yesterday and
we talked about maybe a school wants me
to go in there to a talk or prison
whatever it is it be something and he
said now I'm about to say saying it's
gonna change the rest of your life so I
said what and he went to me guess who
sent us an email last night and I went
home even guess no went who any men it's
a massive brand and I gained right you
wouldn't even compute and I said who he
said Nike and I was like no I don't
believe him I'm gonna send email and
enfold email one and it was a guy called
Dan Smith the works in London head of
track and field and he basically said
that they become aware of my story and
they they felt inspired and at the time
I had like a relationship where I was an
ambassador for a clothing range it was
another sportswear company called Kraft
and they were giving me like t-shirts
activate him
dan said in being like have you got any
contractual obligations and Terry said
to me on the phone he'll it not do you
wanna talk to him or shall I and I said
I trust you implicitly you talk to him
so Terry rang him up and had a
conversation with him in it and it was
to and fro to and fro to and fro then it
went really cold and I was like tend to
be like this means everything buyer to
me what I'm trying to do in my life like
this could age so much to it rich not
just as an athlete but what it allows me
to do and what he represents and and it
went cold it heat back up and then they
said to Terry can John come into the
London office and do a talk to the staff
so military go down to Soho and dude his
talk for an hour and at the end there
was a hundred of a minute it's like a
little cinema and they was all sitting
down on the aisles and in the chairs and
literally there was a line of them
coming out and every single one and took
my hand and laid out and they look like
it's incredible and then Dan was
standing next to me and he went I have
seen them I've seen them being spoken to
by some massive athletes him and I have
never ever ever seen them react to
someone like that and I said to Terry
when we left that talk I said do you
think my light that's got me over the
line with them and so he said you're in
and in two weeks later Dan emails back
and says can John come out to the
Netherlands and talk to our European
conference it be about 850 people from
write global so people from the states
were coming to it so he says to me can
you go I had to ask my patient officer
and I said learn there Mikey wants got
there so they said she said look you can
go say cleared it I got to Netherlands
we go to this auditorium the day before
where we're going to do a practice run
of what we're going to do that day and
then I meet this guy called Edgar and I
didn't realize how powerful it was
within the brand so he's headed VP
market in Europe so he's one of the most
powerful influential Marvin Nike within
Europe so a medium and we go finish
dress rehearsal so we're gonna open up
this massive conference these 850 people
and it was called the power from with
him so it was about normal people
achieving extraordinary things no one in
this auditory
would know anything about me because no
one knew about me in the brand all new
to them so we do I try every dress
rehearsal and then we got for dinner
that night
so we're sitting in this restaurant in
Amsterdam and they'd got sitting next to
me and he was saying to me about you
know do you know how we sponsored you so
I said Dan he said no he said I was
reading about you an airport in in
Holland in Schiphol and I read this
sports supplement and I got halfway
through and he put I put the paper down
I've got my phone out and I sent an
email to London I said find that man and
sponsor him and he was talking to me and
he was telling me a story about years
before that when he was a young guy
working at Nike when he firstly been in
the brand a 32 years and he said there
was a an ice skater in Holland in the
Netherlands and he said the man was
beautiful charismatic charming
good-looking outspoken and I went to the
band and I said about sponsoring him and
at the time not he didn't sponsor ice
skaters and then I always regretted that
we never got him and the next year
become Olympic champion European
champion and he went become this massive
superstar in Holland and I always fall
damn light running wild I've got him and
him and I always promised myself I ever
got to a position in the Brammer I could
make that decision I'd make it a man and
when I saw you my heart told me it was
the right thing to do and and that's how
it all sort of come about and and when
they reached out to me initially
obviously as an athlete is the pinnacle
right by Lance Armstrong was a massive
here are mine in prison I'll read his
books nightly Michael Jordan Mo Farah
Paula Radcliffe all of these endurance
athletes do I aspire to be like what all
under that brand and and to me as an
athlete it meant everything it men like
me realizing a dream what I really come
to realize the power that that has that
night swoosh when you go into schools is
unbelievable to young people and I make
a conscious effort when I go to schools
and I talk to young people I do not
scare them into crime not committing it
because it does not work fact it's been
proven time and time again you can't
scare them but every kid wants to be a
Nike athlete
yes
or there's a rapper or musician or an
actor that is wearing that they see that
as success they don't care about Ironman
they don't care about the records they
see the swoosh and when you're part of
that you're part of like the England
Football team all of these things that
these kids are seeing has been
successful and I can demonstrate to them
and I don't preach I just explain I say
this is a set of decisions I chose to
make as a young man this is what
happened then at that point when I
decided to do that this is what's
happened you don't need to do that to
achieve your dreams in life you can do
two positive things with your life and
you can achieve your dreams that that
doesn't mean every kid's gonna be an
athlete but that night switch to me was
my dream and I said if I have managed to
achieve that my life from being that kid
that was ripped off and spent all those
years in prison and I've made my dream
come real you can make your dreams
become reality and the proofs in the
pudding and when you can demonstrate it
in the show that's those young people is
such a powerful thing like I've gone
into assemblies where there's been like
six seven hundred kids and you can hear
the gasps when you turn around at the
NSA and you go click the slide last
light the light switch and they're like
and they all collapse and out withstand
innovation right and it's so powerful to
really connect into some of the most
disenfranchised young people in the
country
yeah and it's symbolically just
underscores the incredible arc of your
journey because you are in a situation
where you know few people get that low
and there's there's few things you know
more heralded or or you know more
coveted than being a Nike sponsored
athlete like it's just you know that
point to the you know from A to Z is
insane yeah they even and beyond that
like let's not forget the compressed
time period that we're talking about
here this wasn't 20 years ago
yeah when did you get out of prison 2012
2012 yeah that was yesterday man do you
know what when I was writing a book
right so I'm I was fortunate I got often
or changed write a book and it was
really really tough when random when I
got the opportunity was it was hard to
take it because I knew I was gonna need
myself wide open to be critiqued and
people to criticize but I knew that book
would be a key to a door that would give
me a platform to do good with the rest
of my life and I kind of and it was the
reason why I sort of chose to do it and
the ghostwriter that did it with me weed
that we did these sit-ins we used to do
two sit-ins every month and it the book
was written quite oh he was written with
him for months five months but we do
these sit-ins and I'd be telling them
and sometimes after the fire fearless
review I would be I wouldn't be sort of
as open with some of the stories to it
because it embellished that flight I
didn't really want to put so much detail
in some of the stories because I thought
I'd be involving other people that I
didn't really I went to keep the book
all about sort of me and not to about
people because I knew it could open up
Pandora's box of causing me issues later
on in my life and stuff and so I I was
very controlled with how the book was
written and I was very sort of mindful
about what I said and and I remembered I
you sit there sometimes a night you
could see he was like thinking really
like and then um anyway apparently he
never met no one else in the story and
then he met Terry and in him and Terry
met each other one of my races and he
was only conversation with Terry and he
was like is this for real
Terry his eye so he wasn't buying it no
he don't you're full of [ __ ] he kind of
for I think in some ways he thought it
was all pre-planned like I was a
sociopath or I was thinking about this
later on in my life but when I was in
because I was like oh I'm gonna do this
and do this
uh-huh and then he he couldn't get I
think the thing that he really struggled
with was a lot of people helped me for
nothing he couldn't get that everything
is sort of that money it was like but
they must have seen I was they must have
seen something in it like there must
have been something that they must have
seen there was an opportunity in them to
help themselves later on I was then
there wasn't there was none of that but
Darren didn't do what he done all these
years ago thinking that I'd be where I
am today Terry didn't think six years it
got to where I'd be where I am today
like well what's happened there wasn't
and not in sometimes he would sit there
as I said there he sittings with him and
he generally didn't believe it and then
once he got involved then what happened
afterwards
he rings me up now
and nighties my life has never been
normal
like from being a young clearly yeah it
hasn't not even I can admit that lies
some like rich like not many people know
this
so last year I got invited to houses
Parliament to meet the minister to talk
about using sport in prisons and in the
community to stop kids from making bad
decisions right the meeting ends she
says to me would you like to come on the
veranda a parliament to come to this
boxing event so I said yeah so we walk
through I'll go to his boxing event it
was a bit of a showcase it was about
more boxing clubs in London to get more
kids engaged in sport there was add all
these young GB Olympic boxers they was
all doing a Q&A there was a young muslim
got part guy there from bolton and he
wasn't very articulate guy said to him
why did you take up boxing and he went
because i didn't want to be a bum
sitting on the streets taking drugs and
even when i was a kid I watched amir
khan fight at the olympics when he was
16 and i look to me was like at that
time he was 8 9 years old and he went
when I'm when I'm that age I'm gonna go
to the Olympics and fight for my country
and win a gold medal
anyway you went to Rio he come forth and
he was got it and he went when I go back
to take young and win a gold medal for
Britain and I thought this kid is
incredible like he's amazing he's
everything what's paul is to me and then
I left and as I was walking out for the
carpark of Parliament to get a taxi they
all do screaming look up and like from
here ten feet away I walked right into
the middle of a terrorist the terrorist
attack at Westminster and I watched a
guy get shot dead and I saw the
policeman run into walter me and
collapse on the floor and obviously i
didn't realize at the time the guy had
stabbed and stabbed him to death but i
think I didn't see that part of it I
just saw the guy getting shot and and I
remember I got locked in Parliament and
like the whole things on a lockdown it
was completely like you can imagine all
the politicians we all got put in this
like room and then we all got locked
there to like 10 o'clock that evening
and then when I left and you're actually
kind of mentally and emotionally
equipped today and all this in a way
that everybody else isn't even even even
I
even when when it happened is because
you're in an environment where you don't
expect to see what you're about to see
and and that was the thing that took me
out that but what happened when when I
left that night that I remember they let
us out one at a time and they took all
our names and addresses and details and
they said have you witnessed anything I
said I saw the guy shoot him and then
they all stopped and I was like because
they didn't expect someone do you know
you just don't eat policeman's are
taking notes from everyone and then one
guy says you actually saw it and like
what so he took my name address and he
said I okay with you were gonna class
her as a priority witness because you've
actually witnessed the event and I
remember walking out of the houses of
parliament and it was about half 10 11
o'clock at night and the street were
dead like there was no one walking
around there was cordons and you could
you you could see blue lights fishing
but there was no sirens it was dead and
I remember walking out there and I
thought there is no way on earth I saw
that for no reason I there was no way
but the chances of me being there that
moment theme of all those Islamic
suicide bombers all those years before
listening to that young Muslim kid talk
about what sport meant to him and then
coming out and then witnessing that the
chances of me being there were so small
that I thought like I don't believe in
God but I generally believe there's
something where I was meant to be then
see what I saw because it made me
unbelievably driven to continue doing
what I'm doing I can remember that I I
walked home and and I woke up the next
morning and there was a guy that was
with me he was in the army that day and
he tried to save the policeman's life
and he was a battle train medic like
been to Sanders been out to Afghanistan
battle-hardened I it was a hard man in
that regards and I said to him there is
a reason why me and you were there and
saw what we saw to continue doing what
we're doing and he delivers lots of
courses into prisons because what I saw
that day was a man that was
disenfranchised with society that hated
the system I chose to attack it through
taking money from it he chose to attack
it for committing terrorism but
somewhere along the line he got lost
somewhere and someone come into his life
and war
he's where what he thought was right and
wrong and in my head I thought that is
totally preventable you can stop that
stuff from happening by stopping those
people from having that mindset where
someone negative can come in and not
brainwash them but completely warp what
is right and wrong
Yap begins with the disenfranchisement
exactly you know and if you're too late
to address that it's too late and that
stuff happens but that's a profound
awareness I mean that synchronicity of
events is pretty remarkable you know
it's almost surprising to hear you say
that you don't believe in God given like
what you've experienced and how far
you've come and when events like that
that seemingly don't make sense on paper
occur it's hard for me to hear that and
not think that there is a purpose and a
plan and some kind of you know map laid
out for you you know what what was what
was quite powerful I I did a book
festival last year like November and it
was in a very affluent area of the
country when a most expensive places to
live and they invite me to go down and
do sort of a talk about the book
I mean Q&A and I've gone in the room and
I said what's like the demographic for
the area and they read you'll probably
won't get anyone and under the age of 60
uh-huh very wealthy retired very white
middle to upper class so we they start
letting the guests in and I'm sitting
there and I'm looking around but all
these old people and I might they're
gonna they're really gonna start trying
to grill me on the Q&A at the end and
what happened was when we finished they
come up and they were offering me money
they were saying I we want to give you
money like I'm not doing and and I was
saying that I can't take your money but
where my foundations up yeah you got
over foundation yeah yeah that's that
word live a couple weeks ago well and
but I said like I can't take my name if
you remember when he set up please like
I'm please donate to it and and the
money will go to sort of working with
young people and then I'm a priest come
up to me and he went can I ask you
something I said what he said
as your book got a religious
connotations here Redemption and I said
no and he said are you religious and I
said no I said I used to be but I kind
of I fell out of love with I grew up as
a Catholic but I lost that when I went
to prison live I'm honest and the reason
why before I ever used to commit a crime
I always used to pray but get away of it
and on that sounds at what I did I did
like my stepdad was really Catholic my
Nana and granddad devoutly and all got
arrested and I went to prison and that
completely and utterly switch me off I
didn't believe in there on that moment
onwards and he put his hand on my
shoulder and he went to me I have never
seen a man put on earth to do what
you're doing right now even he's so
clear to me when and you might not
believe in God demon but I believe God's
got a bigger plan for you and I know and
again I don't I don't believe but it was
quite a powerful moment where I was like
that's that's that's it and he was
looking at me and I was like wow like I
didn't really know what to say because
it's it was something so above me where
he quite could see something what I'm
trying to do in my life today that I've
been put here for a purpose and I and I
like I said that I believe I don't
believe in God but I do believe things
happen for a reason they're nothing I
was there what I saw that day and I
think my stepdad coming into my life
when I was a kid the people that I met
in prison much that that taught me a lot
of good things you can't just blame him
for sort of warping my perspective of
life he taught me a lot of skills when I
was a kid that have aided me as an adult
one was never just hang around with
criminals and I was a young boy and
always made sure you meet with different
groups of people and that's allowed me
then to be able to converse with
different groups of people all the time
and not be diet I can only talk to like
criminals I can only talk to school kids
right well I would echo that priests
sentiments you know I can certainly
understand why your relationship with
Catholicism fell out of grace but I
think there's a difference between
religious dogma and having a spiritual
connection is something greater than
yourself
that I would certainly you know echo his
thoughts and saying that that you're on
the path that you're meant to be on it's
super inspiring that and it's quite a
remarkable tale and we got to land this
plane but I got to know what's going on
with the crime syndicate now and how's
your mom the crime syndicates fell away
all of them all of them are in prison my
stepdads never been out since I went in
when I was a teen adjuster you go and
visit you stay in contact are you
completely them all out I kind of my
alcohol my on that side of the family
out so you've seen my mom's side but my
mom's side were all legitimate my
co-defendant he got released from prison
recently I found Alan but yeah everyone
else is there even in prison why dead
I'm a mom my mom's good I see him all
the time I'm still really close to her
and she gets all the trophies and medals
and everything all round her house in
vases and but yeah my mum's maker
supportive and so I think it's so nice
now to make my mom proud of what I'm
doing but my mum was always proud of me
even when even when I was in that
high-security prison unit I remember she
come up and she's left wondering two
visits one day and she said to me he was
wondering every time she saw me in
prison but the first time she was like
I'm so proud of you and I was that yeah
mum yeah but she is she's she's your mum
but mums love you gun conditionally and
she always has and he's so nice now like
but when the neighbors say oh I saw
Jonathan on TV or the radio or sees me
the magazine that bounces off it yeah of
course
wow that's so it's such an incredible
story and I feel like it's just
beginning for you thank you
that's the beautiful thing is like this
whole thing is just starting you know
and I see a rich future ahead for you
and the opportunity to impact a lot of
lives thank you so what is the to kind
of end this you know what is the one
sort of sentiment that you want to make
sure you impart to somebody who might be
listening to this who is struggling or
can't find their way forward you know
I'm not talking about necessarily
somebody who's incarcerated but you know
some of you just feel stuck in their
life and is frustrated and and feels
like
opportunity has eluded them I think that
you it I think it's quite simple and I
know you just never give up and always
believe you can get back because it can
and I think life is so precious and
you're alive and you're breathing and
one day we won't
so you're winning the battle because
you're still breathing
and I believe that every day like
there's days I get up and don't you have
a bit of an off day and you just but you
have to be appreciate if I was at my
bike there a day and ride along I
thought wow I'm alive and I love this
now I fly so lovely it's preciouses
we're here that the chances of us being
here right now are trillions and
trillions one you pretty got more
transmitting a lot or a million times
over and that's actually breathing it
so just beep reach it above it and and
just believe that can always get better
no matter how dark that hole is you can
always get out of it and and I've done
it and if I have done it and I either
don't think I'm any different to anyone
else like if I haven't managed to do it
anyone can do anything in life I think
that's a good way to end up it's thanks
for talking to me man thanks really
really incredible much luck in the
upcoming Ironman what are the other
races you're doing this summer I'm
challenged out mirror in the Netherlands
uh-huh
and it is the is the gold qualify for
Kona or what's you know what is the kind
of return to finish as high up in the
field as I possibly can and you know the
mixer everyone very hard to break that
stuff throughout math and then an
Ironman that's all alright we'll come
back and talk to me next time I'm in
London
thanks great let me know if your parole
officer lets you get away alright if
you're digging on John the best way to
connect with him at John McAvoy pretty
much everywhere right and John McAvoy
calm yeah that's it right and are you
ever doing like talks to the public
where people can come and see you like
you have a schedule on your website
appearances not the moment I do boshi
school stuff but yeah and I probably in
the future I probably start doing a bit
more public speaking in the context of
light event but known each diver
schools prisons or maybe sort of
businesses or talks right and tell me
remind me the name of the book
I'm Redemption Redemption yeah I'm glad
all my offers railways and profits go
into school projects aha
and the fit is there a different website
for the foundation ah not commonly No so
you know it's my website but it all the
information to be on there oh all right
man peace I don't know about you guys
but I was profoundly impacted by that
conversation I sincerely hope that you
enjoyed it but more than that I really
hope that it touched something in you
that it catalyzed a shift in your
perspective about your own life your
relationship with gratitude and perhaps
the internal limiter that you place on
your own capabilities but more than
anything my hope is that you take what
you heard today and you translate it
into positive action for yourself and
for the benefit of others do me a favor
let John know what you thought of
today's conversation you can find him on
Twitter at John McAvoy - john2112 a and
give him a push for his upcoming Ironman
I'm sure he'd love to hear from you
while you're at it check out John's book
redemption there's a link in the show
notes to that check out the show notes
as always where I have all kinds of
resources to take your experience of
this conversation to the next level and
if you're looking for some additional
nutritional guidance check out our meal
planner meals dot rich roll comm we have
thousands of plant based recipes
literally thousands I'm not exaggerating
all super customized based on your
personal preferences with unlimited
grocery lists and even grocery delivery
in most US cities with international
cities rolling out shortly all of this
is available to you for just a dollar
ninety a week when you sign up for a
year it is an incredible product last
year we just passed the 1 year
anniversary mark last year we served
over 250,000 plant-based meals by virtue
of this program and it's really helping
people a lot that's what I'm most proud
of and I'm proud that it's affordable
just a dollar 90 a week when you sign up
for a year so to learn more to sign up
go to meals dot retro calm or click on
meal planner on the top menu
my website if you would like to support
my work please subscribe to this show on
Apple podcast or Google podcasts or on
whatever platform you enjoyed this
content share it with your friends and
on social media and you could also
support me on patreon our patrol comm
for / donate and I want to thank
everybody who helped put on the show
today Jason camiolo for audio
engineering productions show notes
interstitial music normally I thank
Blake and Margot Blake Curtis and Margo
Lubin for video and editing but there
was no video on this show but they did
generate graphics so thank you for that
and theme music as always by analemma
thanks for the love you guys see you
back here in a couple days with another
amazing episode and until then be
grateful if you've got one thing out of
today's conversation is that we should
all be grateful for the freedoms that we
have for our ability to move our body
till then be well much love peace plants
[Music]